[Music]
two hello hello everybody it is Friday
July 21st beautiful summer day
it's the H3 podcast we're here
thank you for being here with us we have
a fantastic show today for a change
actually I won't even say that because
yeah because on Wednesday we had a
fantastic show with the one and only
FouseyTUBE so I'll say
two good shows for a change I won't put
him down yeah thank you guys for all the
support on Wednesday's show uh that the
feedback was incredible I knew he was
going to be a good guess you know but
but I I was surprised by how honest and
vulnerable he was and
that that's my favorite type of of
interview it's just so nice to talk to
someone who's
you know so willing to discuss anything
and you know that's I think that's
beautiful so anyway thank you to
SeatGeek for sponsoring this episode
love our sponsors
Ela is not joining us today because
she divorced him
yes I'm sorry guys
just came out I've been showing
everybody in the office my dick I've
been asking everyone for percocets oh
wait sorry that's Stephen Crowder
[Music]
dude this new Steven Crowder article is
crazy yeah
um no uh ELO's not here because this is
just crazy she's actually going to get
pregnant today
why
what I know that's the I know it's like
I we didn't even really think about it
and then we're like oh [__]
so yes
I know it's crazy who's the father
hopefully not the doctor
[Applause]
sneaking his semen in mm-hmm [__] that
uh no but you guys will enjoy this
so
you guys know that we have like six boys
and one girl
we did the girl last month it didn't it
didn't stick so now we have all boys but
they're like well actually you have
three eggs left that we didn't test
oh so he said okay great let's test them
out
we got the results all boys again no
yeah all boys wait yeah you are the most
Alpha human being on the planet you are
only pumping out dude it's insane if I
was King I'd be like this [__] I'd have
heirs for days
that creates conflict too though you
don't you don't wanna whatever bro Min
rule yeah dudes Rockets
I got three heirs potentially coming up
on this
so um so yeah it's gonna be another boy
uh well okay isn't that crazy that is
crazy
so we'll see I'm real nervous about it
it's like you have such a great Dynamic
and you're so nervous about like oh my
God it's crazy going through childbirth
and the first year is like sucks so bad
but then you look at Theodore or not are
you look Theodore's amazing but you look
at Bruce who like I had the same
feelings before he was born
and now he's just like so amazing and
you just you know he's like the greatest
thing ever
so I'm sure it's gonna be like that and
the reason why we wanted the third kid
is because me and Ila both were like
we're both the youngest
she's the youngest of four I'm the
youngest of three
and we're both kind of like unplanned
and so my my theory on that wall was
like
you know
there's this there's this like potential
person out there that you know I'm sure
that if I ever
once once once up once they're here I
couldn't imagine a world where they
didn't exist
my life would feel so incomplete
and so I I think of like a world where I
where my parents used did a condom or
something instead of me being born
[Music]
and uh
I would I like existing personally
as opposed to the alternative which is
not existing I guess although not
existing probably I imagine I wouldn't
have much feeling about it at all
but it was that it was that hey game one
sec
but it was that potentiality of this
living being that
I couldn't imagine living without the
special
the special boy
and that's what pushed us to having a
third
right Gabe
it's an old boy
what's up buddy you're shirtless hot day
huh it's a hot daddy summer baby
you getting some rays
yeah I'm cooling down with a hose right
now oh God
oh that feels great it's a hot daddy
summer [__] it looks cold I know that
hose water ain't warm
yeah you remember did you used to drink
did you used to drink hose water when
you were a kid
yep post water's the best baby
uh hose water going on that shit's
gnarly though like you think about
drinking hose water these days boy um
it's like cooking in that hose man it's
like it's not right it always tastes a
little rubbery but that's okay that's
kind of the flavor yeah
[Music]
water as a kid growing up mm-hmm
yeah builds character so what are you
doing how you been how's your week been
gabo it's good it's good
great excellent any plans this weekend
Barbie and maybe that movie off timer
which is three hours long and [__] me
and Nick they're gonna get a Jam at the
studio making new music oh
oh you got a jam loaded weekend man that
sounds fun you're gonna do the
barberheimer
you guys can do the barmanheimer double
header
probably yeah
I am I am excited to see openheimer I've
heard Barbies very good but I'm just
it's I'll probably see it I'd rather see
Oppenheimer though anyone okay I want to
see both you want to see both they both
look good to me if you could only watch
one which would it be
[Music]
it just it looks it looks I have a
feeling Barbie will be more entertaining
Barbie Hammer seems like the it's like
Madness Opus dude yeah but it's like
it's not gonna be fun I watch you know
what I mean I don't it's like
intellectually stimulating but not like
it's not like a popcorn movie I got a
feeling the oppenheimer's gonna be like
iconic American film of all time yeah I
I am stoked for it it looks crazy and
the fit the feedback is crazy too and I
I love Christopher Nolan he's my fave
he's your favorite director probably at
this moment in time I mean who else is
making interesting films right now
box office James hello
Brian Singer
Jim my boy Jim
James Cameron oh James Cameron well he
makes like one movie a decade and it's
always Avatar
I mean that has been true for the last
decade how do you feel about Avatar Gabe
it's boring
avatars suck you're living in the way of
water right now look at you remember he
went to the theater to protest it I
think yeah I remember he was yeah
avatars lame wow Wales big deal we have
whales in real life nobody cares
we have whales in real life and people
are killing them already so it's like
nobody cares even here on Earth we don't
have turukunzo what's the purpose of
Wales in real life what is the purpose I
know what's the purpose they make great
candles
oh yeah it's perfume too right and
perfume yeah
you know how many candles you can make
from one blue whale
like a couple dozen at least a lot
maybe thousands yeah maybe all right
well um hmm
have a great weekend okay nice to see
you nice to see you shirtless uh what a
nice treat
have a great weekend [__] [__]
[__]
[Applause]
both of my ears so I can't and so much
that I can't hear
[__] out of my booger hole my butter
booger hole okay I like butter Hall what
would the butter hole be
butter holes
can be a lot of things a hole in the
Buttercup a hole in a
butter it'd be like a very lubricated
anus a butter hole a butthole there you
go [__] in my butter hole [__]
[__] on my ear hole and lick it up [__]
[__] how about this [__] in my
ear hole and then clean it up with a
Q-tip baby
[__] on my mouth nice throw it up on
mine
wow excellent
that's powerful image
all right Gabe you have a great weekend
okay
[__] baby Uncle Gabe [__] uh White claw
Uncle Gabe forever
seeing a line of butter holes and
individual who tend to stay home whack
it to comics and The Weather Channel
I'll be here all day awesome thank you
shout out Dearborn
mm-hmm
oh I got you finally oh I had one coming
I I needed that W Gabe thank you that
was a great cutting I want to give a
shout to my girl Frankie Clark who's in
Chicago have fun in Chicago hold the
[__] phone what back back up do you
have a girlfriend
Ah that's my friend Frankie oh so she's
not your girlfriend she's your friend
who's a girl
I'm curious girl that's a friend because
you said girlfriend
it was like girlfriend though thanks to
my hot shout out my girl girlfriend yeah
wait you and I are girlfriends not like
a romantic girlfriend no not a
girlfriend just a friend that's a girl
okay okay got it got it got it because
you you could just say friend and then
it wouldn't confused us
but I suspect there's something going on
there Gabe
I'll get to the bottom of this
someday all right you take care buddy
love you all right all right all right
[__] love you love you [__]
cheers my dude cheers my dude
um
wow Gabe that's uh the artist formerly
known as white claw game right
still gonna take some getting used to it
so yeah um so we're potentially getting
pregnant
today we'll know him like by next week
if she's Craig
another freaking boy dude Mazel Tov
these uh
there was a like last week there was
this night where Bruce and Teddy
like right before bed somehow they have
the most energy of the whole day and
there the two of them were just going
they get so crazy now that Bruce is a
little older and I'm like how do I even
introduce a third one to this equation
like we're just me and either sitting on
the couch and in the middle there's like
this hard Stone
um
table
and they're jumping up they're on the
couch it's like we're just trying to
keep them alive
it's a challenge I don't know how we're
gonna introduce yeah exactly
also yeah so that's that's what that is
um
yeah so that is
also today is a special day it's a
holiday some would say a holy day uh
there's two men in the office whose
names rhyme
whose names rhyme
it would be Cam and dance
now it's not us it's Cam and Dan it's
their birthdays
Dan's birthday's today that's right
happy birthday Dan thank you
happy birthday and what are you turning
47 the 48. congratulations baby huge one
what do you what are you actually 34 36
you old [__] old mother you are so
old yeah thank God you're someone almost
as old as me here 36. and cam how old
are you half a dozen off 482 48 congrats
thank you whoa oh [__] we got sparklers
yeah we got a cape we got cake
uh just pretend
and cam when was your birthday here's my
dude check out the cake we got show that
little camera show to the camera down
cheers my dude cheers
wow cheers my Dan did they give you a
problem at the cake shop
foreign
they're like listen uh I choose not to
work with uh
with anything gay related
um yeah cheers my dude no homo cheers
that of course big tip we call him big
tipster he's the one he's the originator
of that sound bite cheers
what a vagina looks like I know it man
that is a good that's a huge job for you
it's gentle caress that's big tip cheers
my dude
that is a huge dub for big tip
and is this a is this a this is a uh a
cam Dan cake
uh Sam is grabbing another little thing
over there oh we have multiple case we
have another because that's a Dan cake
that's very much a Dan cake yeah
Cameron cam when was your birthday you
know what I I know I know bro I know
very little about tipster so tipster if
you see this this is not this is not a
joke on you I just I just know that I
love that sound bite no no it's not a
joke on tipster by any means no we are
honoring I hear he's awoke King yeah he
genuinely is sound bite of the Year
calling her right now
cheers my dude no it's all love to the
big tip love you I had me don't know a
lot about him either oh whoa what the
[__] is this holy [__] well what we got
what we got
what we got what and got green goddamn
what yeah holy [__] hold up cam got the
mushroom house dude that's [__]
awesome that's badass I know who made
that
show it off
this thing's [__] awesome
holy crap dude that is Sam did you make
this yourself
made that of course incredible dude
that's sick how'd you do that with the
uh how do you call that stuff
that's it fondant fondant yes fondant
and airbrush machine
an airbrush machine a food coloring
airbrush Jesus Sam what don't you have
I don't know I have like everything we
don't have an air conditioner which was
causing a lot of fries no it's literally
uh leaning because our house was melting
it while I was working on oh my God wait
wait wait why don't you guys have AC
what's that about
we just don't it's an old building it's
an old building you guys work in fans
it's like over 100 years old our
building Jesus Christ
we have we have little uh like in window
unit air conditioned okay yes that's
what I had in New York it was it was not
sufficient no yeah it doesn't work very
well well that is incredible Sam thank
you
and is there cake there's cake inside
yeah I've been watching a lot of them is
it cake on Netflix it's very much giving
that which is a high compliment of
course
how do you even cut that thing
and she said it comes off in two layers
she's gonna we're gonna get some cut
cake slices but anyway happy birthday to
the boys can and damn thank you thank
you guys thank you Cameron what's your
birthday my birthday was yesterday oh
yesterday yeah and our do you want to
say your age or you don't want I'm 29
it's fine 29.
young that's a young man right there you
think so I'll take it I feel you know
part right now you're in your 20s bro
what more do you need not for much
longer but I'll take it for now I'm 38
dude you don't understand what that
means dance 36 for God's sakes I was 29
when I started working here
wow wait what seven years
six and a half years well uh because it
was right before my birthday it was in
like June or something so I was only 29
when I started working here for like it
was in June so then it would mean seven
years you've been here
uh no I'm 36.
[Music]
and you said you're 29.
my anniversary isn't today
right you said you started working right
after your birthday
right before so then if you just it's
your birthday now we're gonna crunch the
numbers and it's gonna be seven years
am I crazy no next year is seven next
year is seven years what you say 29 so
you go 30 31 32 33 34 35 36. count those
right that's seven numbers that's seven
digits that are up on my hand right now
it's a good point okay maybe maybe I'm
wrong about that then that's seven
[__] years that's crazy
yeah that is insane I feel like I
haven't been conscious for that long
Dan is the man what can I say you've
been with us for so long good man
um are you still you're having a hard
time with that seven year figure yeah
I mean how am I wrong it's seven years
uh I I guess you're right
I know man I'm just I'm looking back
when I actually started working here too
I know it's crazy bro remembering
well you did just have an anniversary
though yeah like last month like I said
yeah
so was that year seven I thought it was
your six year anniversary but it was
your seven year anniversary
you confused me so much with what you're
saying but wait no what I was saying
made sense I didn't want to get into an
argument with you before I knew that I
was wrong because I started in 2017 it's
the year 2023 is six years jealous
wait wait say that again
go ahead
I started in 2017 2018 28 19. 2020 no
okay 21 2022
2023.
okay now I'm confused just let's please
let's just move on I don't know
no more
so actually we have a really fun episode
and you know Colleen Ballinger is in the
title again and listen guys I don't like
doing this as much as you guys don't but
I mean first of all y'all keep clicking
for It Dummy so don't get mad at me you
know
but I do love talking about it
but we have so much other stuff going on
today on the show we have the sour
challenge which we'll be doing
apparently this is owned by FaZe rug
which hell yeah
I'm not here trying to support FaZe
although I am I like rug
s
love you but I was like damn that's
actually a good idea that he did that so
shout out to Facebook yeah shout out
FaZe rugs
um
we also have
uh all all of her trees calling in I
don't know why
his producer calls he goes all over once
we're calling I'm like okay I guess I
don't know he has two minutes I'll start
the timer he's actually here do you want
to just knock that out right now two
minutes so we're doing the Scorpion
chair Memorial we're doing the NPC Tick
Tock trend
and uh yeah lots of and you put together
a PowerPoint didn't you Olivia
I have like a little thing just a little
presentation yeah yeah because there is
some calling updates
um but yeah let's talk to Oliver I guess
if he's here
not that I don't mind keeping him
waiting if there's one person
all right
you're in La wearing that right now
weirdo freak what what did you say
[Music]
did I stutter
bro I'm not in L.A I'm in Nova Scotia
right now I'm back in my parents spot oh
Nova Scotia
you're not Canadian what I am
you grew up in Santa Cruz
no no that's that's um that's incorrect
I grew up right near the border in Nova
Scotia Canada all right what do you want
what do you want I don't care what do
you want I just wanted to congratulate
you my my fellow skinny Legends thanks
bro that's nice thank you
Oliver as I get skinnier you get fatter
is that great I was gonna say I've been
moving up weight classes and tax
brackets baby let's go oh yeah that's
that's funny but we'll get together
we'll get you you know what I mean we
need to both be healthies uh and and uh
so the next time we box it'll be a fair
match you know I I know I feel like
we're moving into different weight
classes though I'm in the heavy weight
you're going to be down in the
featherweight
by the way mark rubia an actually
talented musical artist and friend of
the show tweeted out my dear bro H3 he
tagged me look at this schvelt
[__] YouTube served me your
stream from earlier today I feel like
I'm looking at 2016 Ethan it's insane
proud of you King thank you Mark rubier
who has excellent music and he he gave
us all free tickets to a show as well oh
yeah yeah he did do that yep so um okay
thanks for the congratulations so how
all right talk to you later buddy no no
no don't go anywhere I have the things I
wanted to run by you
okay see I knew that there was some
other [__] uh okay go ahead it's funny
you talk about this free tickets to a
show because I'm actually going on tour
a world tour and I want you to kind of
giving them out for free okay are you
coming to uh where are you playing in La
it depends how far as it is for my house
uh we're not doing La
um we're actually not doing America at
all we're doing Europe UK Australia and
New Zealand and I got free tickets for
any show of your choosing same with
anybody in the crew gee thanks
so are we gonna be there are we going to
be there what's going on yes put some
tickets out we'll call for all of us
we'll be there at all every show just
like last time man remember when I gave
you and the whole crew and then all of a
sudden you mysteriously didn't show up
bro I don't remember that's not how I
remember it exactly I know there's some
conflicting reports because I remember
texting you and your guy and we're like
we're coming and you guys were like
crickets so I wasn't sure you texted me
and I texted back immedi ately I said
hey you're good don't worry about it we
got you and then all of a sudden you
know there's 20 spots in the guests for
you and your entire crew and their
families and then he's there and I'm
like yo the show was sold out and it was
actually a very disrespectful thing so I
wanted to have you publicly apologized
for that actually if we could well to be
honest with you we usually when we go
somewhere we need at least 80 guests um
tickets because Zach brings quite an
Entourage with them
San Diego sold out uh 20 limit guest
list by the way just I love it what's
that man my San Diego show what about it
it's sold out wow congrats thank you but
there's only 20 guestlist spots I've
made that very funny nope no plus no
[__] 20 that's it that's right
that's what I'm talking about good man
dude congratulations how many seats you
saw in San Diego I think it's a 250 cap
room that's a smaller Club but um that's
gonna be so fun though yeah good for you
bro thank you you hear that Oliver
there's actually a musician here selling
out seats
always been such a big fan Zach and uh
you know if you ever want to come to one
of my shows and see what a real concert
looks like you call me because we got
tickets for you wait and that will call
so so what so what do you want to do you
want you want people to go see you in
those in those spots
well I would love that actually yeah
we're uh we're doing pretty crazy
extensive tour
um name one Zach Lewis song
[Music]
um wake me up before you go go
correct
or my Wham my George Michael here like
all right well guys you can go ahead and
go to olivetree.com to pick up tickets
that's not the [__] website as you
guys can see he also sells Bible app for
Bible study and stuff so it's actually a
One-Stop shop olivetree.com no it's
Oliver tree
music.com well this is just easier to
type in it's shorter olivetree.com and
here's millions of people
you have testimonials here which is
really strong the courage that's on my
website Grammy award-winning musician
says my day starts and many times ends
with olive tree oh he's a big fan the
app is intuitive and easy to use I use
the French and Spanish translation in
tandem with English the notes and
resources are right on point Bravo stop
stop
oh
you seriously knock it off and just go
to my website maybe read off some of the
places I'm playing
I that's definitely what I did wait hold
on I literally just did that it's Oliver
tree music
are you finding that website Dan
send me a link wow that does kind of
look like you on there
I'm not sure if this is it but and are
you gonna be having
um a trapeze during your show are we
gonna get like an elephant standing bit
maybe some clowns funny you say that
yeah we're actually gonna do it's kind
of like an Intergalactic talent show
kind of vibe mixture of a TV show a
movie a concert and a play and uh I'm
very very proud we're actually losing
money to do this
can I ask you a serious question is this
the only place you sell tickets to your
shows I mean like it seems like every
time
and you got to sell some tickets you
come here otherwise I don't think
anybody would be at your shows clown
that hit you hard huh
that hurt that one hurt
two-thirds buddy can we at least get a
code H3 so I could get some affiliate
[__] going oh yeah yeah yeah I got you
some free merch I'm actually doing Tall
beanies now and uh I've been designing
some big coats for winter
can you send me his URL Dan I wasn't
able to find it I did I did sent it oh
you did thank you so Olive Tree music
okay
so let's see um is this it though I'm
still a little unclear where do you buy
it sure
oh yeah it should be the forward slash
tour
I don't see anywhere to click wow how do
I buy tickets
um
huh album
basically
album was announced
I'm really excited I've been working on
it for three years and then yesterday
dropped a music video the second
installment from the album uh one and
only and um I'm very proud of it went to
film it in Serbia and uh I think it's
some of my best work yet I'm very very
excited about it but how do I buy
tickets oh thank you oh I got the mouth
this is honored piece thank you
my dude
all right is there anything else
I have actually
what you're gonna eat all that no
probably not
um yeah I was also um we're selling
vinyls so uh the album is actually doing
uh hey can we cut back to me can you we
don't need to see that clip right there
I don't know what that has to do with
anything so it's just some kinetic sand
too um basically I started working back
with uh the labels you ever play Subway
Surfer this guy Sean schneebly who works
at the label he actually recently just
told me that the vinyls will be coming
out the day of the actual album release
crazy pretty big deal because when we
did it initially on the first album it
took nine months during coven that's
crazy bro
you turn off that [__] screen I don't
I don't know what you're talking about
it's gone now go on no everybody's
listening go ahead let's go so we're
selling these crazy bundles with these
vinyl packs and I can you cut back to me
really quick I have something important
to say
That's crazy dude so we're trying to
take this thing number one uh I'm really
excited about this it's Ethan I won't
even know this right that's crazy dude I
can't believe that you've been listening
to me
okay I've been traveling the world right
I've been on the floor from Nova Scotia
all the way to Europe that's unreal I
know that's what I'm saying and bro it's
crazy because of course I met so many
all right well it looks like we're out
of time Oliver there's so many fans as
usual it's always a pleasure wait you
gotta hear the new songs
sounds good buddy please don't go
anywhere.com
there's no dates
I appreciate that all right
myself on this
all right nice to hear from Oliver tree
as usual
that was one of the best clubs we've had
with them I was just eating the cake and
enjoying the voices with Nook I mean
he's palatable with that
um
is he gonna send us to a link without
any ticket how am I supposed to buy
tickets dummy there's literally no link
like come on bro
oh look at that if you type in Slash
tour like you said you actually do see
the dates Slash tour yeah okay I'll
Trust I'll let people do that
tour okay cool bye
should have a link to it on that on his
main URL like shouldn't have to explain
that to him but okay whatever
um
moving on so let's talk about foosi we
had this great great interview with him
on Wednesday
and we've all been debating how long
before he gets banned he got banned I
what do you get banned for and when did
he get banned it's a suspension not a
band he got banned uh around three 3 30
A.M last night yeah
um for sleeping no no it was
he showed me the email it was like
sexually suggestive content
I think uh he's not sure exactly
actually what moment it was
he shot dick he did show dick it wasn't
that because it time stamped it from
last night's stream
oh something happened last night yeah he
doesn't know what um
I'd love to know what it was
maybe he would beat off in his sleep
like he mentioned something like that
happening potentially I I
well anyway
um there was some touching moments after
the podcast that everybody on the
subreddit was was loving so I'll share
them here with you guys
foosi we'll see as we're calling him
wussy woob
Amy you really gotta be in his ear
though he's gonna get permanently banned
I was literally like
because he's been calling me every day
since the podcast we're boys now yeah
and I was literally like planning on
telling him like Hey have a good time
this weekend because I took him to the
airport but don't get banned please
don't get banned I need this and
literally on the way to his house he
texted me he's like bro I just got back
no but for real he's gonna get
permanently banned because he doesn't
know like he can't stream with
Aiden Ross you can't do that at all
apparently right so he's got to be
careful there was other stuff you were
pointing out right love yeah he could
get a permaban with the stuff he's
already done what can what does he need
to avoid
he's not showing his deck okay right
that's an easy one I'm saying that he's
gonna jerk off you can't even say You're
Gonna jerk off of course not no what do
you mean what do you mean of course not
I don't think he said that he said
something else though during the stream
well he admitted to it on the show okay
so if you're like I need to go to the
bathroom and jerk off that's no go I'm
pretty sure that's no-go I can do that
on YouTube
yeah twitch I think in my opinion that
would get you about the free warning at
least
um not from now on when I need you to
the bathroom I want to say I'm going to
the bathroom to jerk off be right back
don't don't say that yeah it sounds
gross that's not good the bomb threats
bomb threats yeah yeah
that's his fault how does he prevent
that from happening not having TTS
having mods filter stuff oh yeah
obviously screamed like when that after
that went off he like screamed a bunch
of shops scared people that when he
shouted right yeah he's just praising
the Lord that's it that's right he's
just saying recording people in public
uh like when he's in a restaurant people
like looked uncomfortable behind him he
can't do any of that can't do that wow
technical like technically
okay so he's got to be he's gonna get
banned I don't think he's yeah he's not
gonna lie I was sitting here in the
office like he's gonna get banned
tomorrow or the next day 100 maybe he
well he can he can move to YouTube if he
gets banned right I mean YouTube's
YouTube's good well anyway here here's
fousey right after uh the interview he's
on his way home
by the way did not dox us
King you know everybody was saying he's
gonna dox you he did not dox us he was
very respectful yo thank you H3 family
like if this is if this is the only time
you ever watch me thank you from the
bottom of my heart man for literally
just giving me a chance to tell my story
and not being like Oh I'm not gonna
watch this guy
he would be thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you just
for [__] listening
thank you thank you he's a sweetheart I
love him I re you know and and that's I
think everybody really had uh was very
endeared to him it was I gotta tell you
the part when he was talking about how
he comes immediately and all this stuff
about the massage parlors that was
fascinating to me I mean I I loved being
brought in on that world because it's
just
yeah I didn't know that there's like
they'll ha they'll have sex with you
that is crazy
I did feel a little bad when I was
saying that I had a similar problem when
I was younger and then he said 30
seconds I was like oh it wasn't I don't
think it was that bad for me no this is
like five seconds or five whatever it
was this is like immediate Stolen Valor
a little bit so okay take light of his
struggle you're backpedaling a little
bit I mean I just I didn't know 30
seconds like well what are you talking
like a minute two minutes we talking ten
minutes a couple minutes I was younger
getting nervous that's just that's just
being young
yeah I kind of realized after he's you
know what I mean that's just being young
but my boy fousey it's he says if you
breathe on it he'll I mean it sounds
like a real issue
he's been through it man
oh my God my bad
even though we're not close even though
we're not close no this was great this
was this was very sweet my dad has gone
through just as much as my mom has with
me and Dad has been through so much man
I can't hate on my dad
hi
Baba I was just on one of the biggest
podcasts in the world thanks bro mom I
was just on one of the biggest podcasts
in the world yeah what do you mean one
of hold on hold on hold on what the [__]
do you need one of
thanks Dan for pointing that out
uh a guy named h3h3
yeah was he just this big YouTuber
oh apparently you can get banned for Dr
being on your phone while driving
yeah that kind of makes sense if you're
reading chat but yeah he has it on TTS
so that he's not looking at it so he's
good in that regard you think he he
makes he picked up his phone and he was
not watching like what he was doing
calling his dad what he was doing is
illegal yes it's that is illegal to like
pick up your like I know everybody does
that but like that so that's a yeah just
in terms of like in terms of service I
could imagine that's popping you on that
too [__]
the thing is he doesn't want to go to
YouTube I mean I I I know he does it
yeah he's not gonna have a choice pretty
soon it's kind of like a new beginning
for him yeah I don't know
people watching live
yeah it went really really really good
Baba
yeah
you guys keep schooling like that I'm
gonna try really hard this time I told
you
yeah but be careful
that's it I will I will I'm not uh all
I'm buying is food after the car I'm not
buying anything else
okay but try to find cheaper to me
tired
than the four thousand dollars okay
you gotta love it's like he can't help
but just be like hey I'm glad you're
doing good but dude you gotta
stop spending money it's like he's
worried you know
it reminds me of iola's dad there's this
hardcore Middle Eastern
but incidentally they're both from the
same place if he's Palestinian yeah it's
yeah nothing's nothing's good enough
when I went back home last time my dad
asked me he goes are you still working
on the show or are you are you only
boxing out there I'm like only boxing at
the time I'm like I did one match and I
lost what are you talking about damn
you're dead is really yeah
you're a boxer now son are you a
full-time boxer athlete yeah
I don't know that's awesome
okay
Mom I love you
wow
yes you know that's the first time you
ever told me I love you too in my entire
life gay stop
the last time Bubba I was live on stream
yesterday I said I love you you said
okay good that that made me laugh
I love you okay good
so maybe I'm thinking of something first
time you've ever said I love you
and I love my kids more than myself
future I know that
is maybe I don't show it but even one of
you wants my eye I'll give it
I know about it you you're always the
best father
thank you thank you
peace and love forget my mama yeah I did
okay
[Music]
thank you
very it's a little bit long but yeah
it's very sweet rip my heart out of my
chest that was so beautiful yeah it was
so sweet his dad didn't even deny it
it's fine his dad seems sweet in this
phone call but I think he got him
those Middle Eastern parents they're
hard man they're hard asses
I his dad used to be in his videos a lot
oh really yeah many years ago when I
used to watch him a lot he's really
funny his dad yeah sounds funny yeah
it really goes to show how having a
positive experience with positive people
can have a ripple effect the sun just
shines a bit brighter Smiles come easier
and you just want to share that energy
top comment you see
hmm
beautiful
although it wasn't long before fousey
got home and started arguing with Bryce
Hall
Bryce saw two friends of the show here
let's see take a look though just saw
some clips of h3's podcast and saw fusi
say he could expose me for a bunch of
things I do because he's known me for so
long
what is his sub tweet High School
[__] don't say you know [__] about
me then proceed to say a bunch of
nothing old you old [__]
old I mean with the old stuff come on
bribery your best friend is Ryan
Kavanaugh how old is that dumbass
if he thinks fousey's an old [__] what
does he think about kavkev
uh okay foosi responds God bless you
Broski best of luck on your BK FC fight
okay he uh he found out about this tweet
right before he was about to enter his
um therapy that he does yeah um and he
was in the waiting room you know he he
just he had this the support from his
friend I forget her name but like Just
Let It Go just Let It Go just love or
hate dies love wins yeah
what did he say about Bryce he did he
said something like that but I think I
correct me if I'm wrong I remember I
think what he said was just in reference
to the fact that he said that in that
clip because you guys were reviewing the
clip from that reality show and in that
clip that was what like set Bryce off
was fousey said I know [__] about you or
whatever I remember fousey just it was
like he was explaining the story I don't
think he was like doubling down on that
claim but I could I could be
misremembering I don't know does anybody
else remember I remember him saying I do
know stuff about him but I'm never gonna
do anything because okay so he did kind
of double down on that I think so I
think so
uh but I mean it doesn't seem like that
serious God bless you Broski love wins
Bryce Hall says everyone knows the real
me because I'm the most authentic real
social media personality there is okay
slow down slick
I'm exactly the same person as I am on
camera and the fact this fart hole hey
tone down the language buddy fousey is
putting out a false Narrative of my
Persona because I slept with his
slept his dumbass I was like slept with
left his dumbass a year ago is just
Petty take the L and stop drinking
alcohol you [__] okay that's come on bro
first of all he's sober
so that that that's below the belt okay
second off everybody knows I'm the
realest social mediae personality I'm
the realest social media personality
there is
I'm exactly the same person as I am on
camera you fart hole
also he's into the word [__] right now
that's very like kind of British insult
is it not calling somebody a [__] called
Church probably he's cultured yes
where's fart hole from whose version is
that from that English
has been sober since the incident for
Friday date 9 15 you should do the same
you got a point Bryce does seem to have
he doesn't seem to drink a lot
um
I've been sober for over a month because
I can control my vices okay dude stop
he's been sober why you got to do that
I don't touch people when they don't
want to be touched when I drink alcohol
can you say the same
okay I can't he says hence why
responsibly quit drinking alcohol
addiction is real and some people can't
control their vices true
happy to hear you're getting better now
when you explain your journey about
recovery you can leave the subtle shots
at me out of it fair
thank you I tried texting you explaining
you have a new number I was explaining
my perspective from that day wasn't
trying to expose in the presence or
rehash this I will not mention you any
more moving forward love okay well this
is this was a that was a love wins again
that was a nice exchange good job love
wins again
by the way this is a pretty epic copy
pasta
I everyone knows the real me because I
am the most authentic real social media
personality there is
by the way he called uh he called fousey
Old here he is with his best buddy Ryan
Kavanaugh
God he has yellow teeth don't he wow
it's rough teeth are vile thank you
he gotta hit up uh fousey's guy yeah
right
I don't know if he has a hundred
thousand for new teeth though he's been
on he's down on Hard Times
so um yeah as of this morning fousey got
banned for three days and is there
anything he can do I mean he says I'm
doing a 24-hour sub-a-thon I've been
live for 21 days
flight in Nashville for all access
footage to Misfits 08 three-day
suspension will literally end me what
can I do yeah that's that timing sucks
huh it's weird sometimes on Bottoms
people early yeah he he appealed it sent
them a message so
hopefully they do okay
have a heart twitch give him this one
yeah speaking of kavkav at the top of
the show there it's just one funny thing
we'll get into the segments look at this
[__]
this is the dumbest man alive
okay here's Ryan Kavanaugh
now let me read this and tell me if you
noticed something
so he says wildfires are blaze in
California once again we're committed to
mitigating their effects from the sky
and ensuring everybody's safety keep
safe everybody who's weird who who the
[__] we who's we dude why are you
posting this you freak
by the way I haven't heard anything
about wildfires are they happening
I mean it it's hot and it's California
so probably somewhere there is see wow I
just haven't heard of anything where
he's like I don't think there's any like
giant ones quite yet is Ryan trying to
get clout from forest fires I just
what's the Wii
does anyone find it strange that when my
kids ask what Daddy did at work today
this is the work day snapshot for Dad
the [__] are you talking about you can't
even drive a car because he drinks and
drives why is he is he flying a
helicopter right now wait wait what are
you talking about Ryan
are you saying that you're Manning this
helicopter
what the [__] well here's the best part
sure here are some relevant hashtags
that could help your post reach a
broader audience
hashtag California wildfires hashtag
firefighting from the sky hashtag say
save California hashtag firefighters at
work hashtag Daddy on duty hashtag
Wildfire Heroes
Daddy on duty
climate action now did he does he have
like a all that's like a firefighter and
he posts the wrong account allegedly we
we allege that he has who's my daddy he
has fake instas one of them is a surfer
what was this like hot Surfer boy yeah
yeah
420 who is supporting him and this is
the strange strange post my friend
and by the way I don't know who's did
this but somebody's all just got exposed
with the ollie London Avatar
um is this post still up yeah okay link
me I gotta I gotta see this to believe
it I'm alleging things I don't know
anything maybe Ryan is a firefighter
maybe Ryan is a firefighter in his free
time
maybe maybe Ryan is a wildlife
firefighter Manning search and rescue
highly specialized October uh uh uh
choppers that load up water and drop
them
he's a real daddy on duty that's it talk
about daddy on duty wow 35 000 likes so
organic it's so organic wait here's the
wait hold on it's got a um it's got a uh
Watermark Steve white boy who's Steve
Whitby
that's probably just the photographer
that snapped that shot right
but oh yeah let's look at the really
authentic comments here thank you for
your service you are amazing ask for
more hashtags you've got this
cheers keep it up hon thank you left in
your AI hashtag generator though cheers
I love this
that's it five comments 35 000 likes
super organic oh [__] I hear a
helicopter above us right now that's
Ryan he's he's coming he's going
he looked up water he's repelling from
the helicopter as we speak onto the
ceiling yeah the dude who's not allowed
to drive because his license was revoked
is Manning a helicopter good point
allegedly that's what I believe is
alleged he did have some
what was the oh right didn't he uh get
in trouble with the city for yes
I don't think he was he wasn't piloting
them no no as far as I'm aware what
happened was his neighbors complained
because he was like illegally Landing
his helicopter in his neighborhood
real down to earth guy like that
yeah
this is just so bizarre Ryan can you
explain this
why have you posted this
why have you done this well look at all
the positive comments he's getting okay
what is that social from that very real
uh social marketing Network social
marketing wow I love this let's check
him out
social marketing Network oh yeah this oh
yeah I love this page bro
social marketing Network 509 dude I love
this page
the one
Venetia
oh man that's great this page is awesome
this is one of my favorite pages
this is one of the five commenters he
allowed
wow that's so authentic
crazy let me see the other one um
wow I love this same comment from
prippyboy11 wow I love this
oh yeah dude this way I love this page
too this is prep Boy 11. Pretty Boy yo
check out this page this is the other of
five commenters
prippy boy you all look money goes up
it's the richest boy in school it's the
credit bank cash app Zell PayPal check
this one out fantastic Bank Republic
these are great I can almost take out
the last word Bank
Maybe
I don't know hard to make out that word
not a lot of pixels
it's a picture of a it's a drawing of
the bank oh yeah it's awesome
that's fantastic well
nobody can ever accuse Ryan of not
having a ton of fans
[Laughter]
this person said thank you for your
service you are amazing this one varies
a little bit let's take a look
uh they may have just oh no this one's
real I think they probably just stumbled
upon the hashtags and assumed that he
was a firefighter
because of the fact that it said that he
was a firefighter this one is super real
looking or maybe it is real though
no I think they they might have just
stumbled into it and thought it was an
actual firefighter the hashtags did work
in that case what an idiot what a
[__] idiot Ryan you're a [__] you
spend so much money trying to do this
[__] and they all suck thank
you thank you here I'll make you an
offer Ryan
just drop all the [__] let's just come
to terms and I'll help you with your
social media [__] a bit
a little bit
our two like best friends with Bryce
Hall what is friends don't let friends
drive drunk and and what I mean by that
is it's an analogy friends don't friend
friends don't let friends post that kind
of [__] to Instagram
[__]
God what an idiot
all right let's talk about our sponsor
let's talk about it
seat geek I love seat geek can y'all fix
that or is that like a technical issue
it's a technical issue okay hold on just
a little technical issue here we have
some technical issue it sounds like we
do about it what are we gonna do
[Music]
let's start over
wow I love seeking let's start over
[Music]
quite a bit of my time that's the first
one we've had during an ad
first time for everything I just thought
let's go back let's let's rewind it
wasn't I said something bad it was just
the vibe was off yeah the vibe The Vibes
were off
I said something I'm like they usually
don't like when I say that
yeah see geek man
I use them to get like Dodger tickets
for my dad like behind the plate
exclusives the one thing I really liked
about the sea geek is that when I was
getting tickets for like a ball game
you get to see exact view from the sea
so you know if there's like a beam in
front of you
know
let's be real
that happens sometimes
uh with over 28 million downloads C geek
is the number one rated ticketing app
wow they've grown good for them
there are more than 70 000 events every
single day on seek geek including
concerts Sports festivals and more
here's what I'm going to recommend
uh Hamilton's still on Broadway in New
York
next time I go to New York which is
coming up I'm definitely going to see
Hamilton again I love that show if you
haven't seen it go see it
it's uh
it's playing ever I think it's like
every day still it's on down
the the Richard Rogers theater and
Broadway on Broadway baby
on Broadway
and uh well here in La one that's going
to be easier for me is Beetlejuice at
the Pantages
Beetlejuice which gives me flashbacks to
Trisha but I'll try to sit through it
the girl in it is really really
incredible I like Clips yes
well there it is
I don't have tickets but I would love to
get tickets with Seiki that's right
there's artists like Taylor Swift post
Malone Drake 21 Savage Beyonce they're
all on tour you can get them all on
SeatGeek they put all of a tree on sea
cake if they didn't mention Oliver tree
because I think they actually want
people to go there they name like
actually known artists yeah exactly
exactly
um they put all the tickets across the
web in one place to make sure you're
getting the best deal each ticket is
rated on a scale of one to ten so look
for a Green Dot green means you're
getting a good deal red means you're
getting a bad deal every ticket is
backed by the buyer guarantee and
SeatGeek is the only site that lets you
return your ticket ahead of the event
with swaps well that's all sounds really
really really good
yeah I'm a big fantasy geek they're
great check them out
uh use my code after Dark
for 20 bucks off
seat said Seafood that's a great deal
that's good that's nice that's 20 bucks
off your first purchase
both promo code after dark make sure you
click the link in the description to
download the app so thank you so much to
uh Seiki consider supporting them uh if
you want to support the show thank you
so much
yeah let's get it
[Music]
okay let's go
all right so listen we got we got
Colleen in the freaking thumbnail again
I keep being like girl stop talking so I
can move on
but you guys can't be mad at me right
like I mean come on
yeah you guys eat it up and frankly I
love it too but it gets a little
embarrassing that I have to keep putting
it in the title every time but I'd be a
fool not to
you know All Aboard all aboard the is
the Colleen you train I think I lost the
tone a little bit
All Aboard [__] me right okay so
actually here's a follow-up from our
coverage and this is actually Pro
Colleen Ballinger uh in fact I was
thinking about titling this Colleen
Ballinger's 100 innocent was that too
dicey yeah it's true in this case
um
so we did a test because Colleen's
lawyers and her were claiming that she
never went and claimed people's videos
and so we said okay let's we can find
out if that's true or not so Dan went on
CD Baby
and cl he's like I'm gonna claim one of
your songs I there's zero proof
zero evidence random information so
we've went to the site put in totally
unidentified information and then we
said we owned this song by Ethan Klein
and guess what to be to be clear just to
be fair to CD Baby it wasn't totally
random I just used
your information but nothing that isn't
publicly known like just your name in
general info about you
you know I don't but I don't even know
that they even care you could have just
said your name and your birthday and
they'd be like cool right and it
wouldn't matter because I could just I
could have just put in Colleen's name
and put up the Colleen song and
pretended I was hurt well we don't know
if they actually care about that info or
not though yeah but I'm just
that was the way I went about it I put
in that I am Ethan Klein and this is my
song so um last night I got an email
from YouTube is it in here should be
you guys not the claim yeah the claim is
uh in the next link
uh and
the uh drum roll check this [__] I got
I got claimed because of that [__]
can you believe how dumb that is
so I gotta say I think this 100 acquits
Colleen
yeah see it says you were claimed by
Ethan Klein so that's right there that's
insane
don't know how something and I gotta say
Colleen got a lot of [__] for this
and she I don't think she did anything
right she's
clearly not the worst thing she's been
accused of in the past year I feel like
yeah yeah
like whatever just a loser you didn't
claim your horrible song that you did
actually right and perform in post not a
not that big of a deal right right fair
in the scope of things but what I do
well it's the one thing their lawyer
seems to care about but the last thing
I'll say is
CD Baby
they need to be held to account for this
you know why they call it CD baby it's
not CD it's like CD like a CD bar Shady
Baby
[Music]
that's a pretty good play on word so you
think CD Baby I see it's a shady baby
okay okay
I was stunned by this frankly
stunned stunned and we thought oh maybe
they got wise after the calling thing
claimed my [__] video oh and here's
the best part
you can't drop it if this happens you
cannot drop it they says the quickest
way is just dispute it through YouTube
so if this happens
you have to wait 30 days for this dumb
[__] to be cleared
and you're just relying on I guess a CD
maybe employee taking a look at it I
don't think so I think it just expires
if they nobody responds it gets released
after 30 days I see so it doesn't even
have a human touch anywhere yeah I was
shocked I thought for sure because you
know in your account on there it gives
you the option of do you want to sync
your stuff with YouTube and collect
revenue from there which basically means
they start claiming on your behalf
um I figured there would be some sort of
uh dashboard or interface where you
could see the Flames no it's completely
out of your control out of the artist's
control and what's interesting is you
didn't put in any payment information or
anything so CD Baby is collecting the
revenue for this to somewhere right
taking the money somewhere right
yeah because theoretically I don't get
paid out if I finish the process of uh
giving them tax info to pay me and
everything this this is a real problem
and I I just here's my dispute hey
dumbass this is my song
proof of ownership that's my proof of
ownership
um
I don't know what to do about this but
this is stunning that in this year 2023
on YouTube this is a thing
like can I just go claim a Taylor Swift
song
there was
so when you go to publish it
and you type in a name like I typed in
Ethan Klein or whatever and it gave me a
number of existing accounts on Apple
music and Spotify yada yada and if I
wanted to uh apply it to that and then
there was like a review process if it
was somebody like Taylor Swift or
something I'm sure they have it
blacklisted that like random people
can't so I gotta try to find the most
famous person that's not blacklisted and
steal every one of their songs right
well no and and see it you
you didn't have I guess an Ethan Klein
Spotify account you you do have some of
your music on Spotify but it's it's
listed as the jokes or something right
yes so it just created one and through
so you owned the Ethan Klein uh I own
Library your library thanks bro I'm
suing you by the way
you'll be served soon I know where you
live
but yeah it just it seems very
um not totally thought out this whole
process and frankly I mean I'm you I'm
sure you agree but it seems like it's
just as much of a YouTube problem as it
is CD Baby YouTube just makes it so easy
for people to get away with this
yeah I'm trying to I mean okay
like that they can just come in and
claim something without any proof
they need I think yeah I think both
parties need to be looking at this
seriously yeah I think YouTube needs to
be looking seriously at these huge mega
claimers
the problem is YouTube really they're
complying with laws
there is a dmca law there's a claiming
law
that allows websites like YouTube to
exist where people post content so I
blame them less than CD baby okay
[__] you CD Baby CD Baby
here is um
I hope Colleen Susan man that'd be great
do it for us do something good for us
you know
that'd be a dub
it wouldn't really help though would it
no not with the child grooming I don't
think but she's only groomed her cats
what are you talking about the Persian
cats
oh you know somebody just point
something out in the chat that I just
realized remember you
listen to that Fan's music
on your member stream recently right and
then it like Auto claimed and you kept
asking her to remove it and she was like
I'm trying I now now seeing what it's
like I understand why she wasn't able to
get that taken care of it seems like
their process is crap like but if she if
she can't help that they're claiming my
stuff how am I supposed to ever watch
their content or anybody you you are I
agree right yeah it's like there's no
even if you wanted to whitelist it said
that you you just have to kind of do it
manually get in contact with somebody at
CD Baby the other distribution platforms
uh allow you to check
um whether you want it claimed on
YouTube
in here too yeah but it was an All or
Nothing thing it was either it's on and
they claim everything or you just turn
it off and it doesn't touch YouTube at
all I know the two options the one I use
you are able to whitelist certain okay I
mean which one is that let's plug them
uh distrokid okay this got a better
system yeah kid
here here's disputing releasing and
handling monetization yourself when to
contact YouTube the best and quickest
way to have CD Baby release a claim is
to dispute the claim within your YouTube
account thanks you mean you do nothing
this link shows you exactly how the
process works and the steps you take
within YouTube bro you're stealing my
money
and just taking it into nothing it's
shocking it's shocking so that kind of
blew me away so uh
there you go Colleen eat your heart out
but the next stuff we've got not not as
good
not as good for her all aboard so we
have a little bit of a mini PowerPoint
here yes I just threw it together don't
expect too much but it does give a
rundown of what happened so her lawyers
put out a statement right which is her I
guess acknowledging
everything
to an extent we'll brush over everything
but variety released an article
pretty much in support of Colleen and
the only people they reached out to for
comment were Colleen's wait what I
didn't read that yeah they didn't reach
out to any of them an article supporting
her they didn't this article that I'm
going to take you through they're pretty
much like it's a puff piece
and they didn't reach out to Adam they
didn't reach out to Johnny they didn't
reach out to anybody righty
yes
um
that's that's insane I mean we're just
like James Charles had that puff piece
just the other day it's like the cosmo
all right let's see okay so in Colleen's
defense Gaslight gatekeep girl boss
groom alleged allegedly allegedly
so Vanity Fair released an article how
the Miranda Sings Colleen Ballinger
Scandal went off the rails All Aboard
everything you need to know about the
drama tearing YouTube apart by Andrew
Quintana I wouldn't say it's tearing
YouTube I wouldn't say that either I
think that tearing her out of YouTube I
agree with that I think there's a pretty
unified Coalition against Miss Colleen
we've all Allied yeah and peace
so next
I think the intentions of this article
are to downgrade and attempt to minimize
Colleen's offenses to smear the face
hold on let me back up you want to talk
about it no you're talking about this
Vanity Fair because you said yes I'm
talking about this article
oh my God Vanity Fair vanity okay I'm so
sorry not variety not variety vanity I'm
so sorry the V the other V the other V
alrighty I have always thought it's very
reliable that's what I think that's what
I thought didn't they write that article
about Ryan Kavanaugh doing the Ponzi
scheme yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
didn't do this one they would never
and they're retracted they wrote that
article which was retracted correct yes
yes yes Vanity Fair very unfair but the
reporting on it was good but the
retraction was added to it
okay go ahead sorry to downgrade an
attempt to minimize Colleen's offenses
to smear the face of the movement Adam
McIntyre by painting him out to be a
liar and a stalker and having him be the
only person named besides Colleen uh
intentionally exclude the narratives at
the core of the story and writing the
kids accusations off as baseless and
unsubstantiated that's a quote so I
wrote how who where unsubstantiated how
did I not hear about this
except two days ago I told you
this is pretty stunning tell you all
about it on Friday who would stick their
neck out for her at this point okay
so you you want to know the author of
this article's name is Andrew Quintana
um his author's bio states that he
graduated from Bennington writing
seminars in 2023 with a degree in
creative nonfiction creative right with
this emphasis
The Narrative possibly Liberties that
were taken
um he's an educator an aspiring personal
essayist and resides in Los Angeles with
his husband
um he posted on his hold on you missed
the most important part
and his Schnauzer right obviously Keith
sorry Keats I mean he's watching
actually
shout out shout out Keith so before
Andrew privated his Instagram
um he posted a tweet about the situation
or uh he posted an Instagram about it
and said misinformation online is
rampant only believe in trusted reliable
sources I've been reporting on this
topic for the last week Lincoln bio and
he's the only trustable reliable source
yeah and he also before anybody is like
why are you talking about this uh the
author he tagged Adam deliberately so I
see that yes
and then when he got pushed back he went
private so so he's already been like
bullied out of existence I mean
bullied out of existence or like told to
retract you know what I mean here's what
I'm gonna say I have nothing to do with
it he's already private baby yeah I
didn't nobody say I did [__] yes yes yes
listen I always say this
do not bully people do not go after them
anyone we talk about on the show do not
go and cause them [__]
that being said he's already private
nobody can put this on me
dummy
also he chose to write this article and
put his name on it
two
do we dare take a peek
we dare we dare so I have pulled yes
so this article uses coercive and
misleading verbiage wow for example when
stating Colleen's offenses they say
buried into like sandwiched in a
sentence Ballinger would be accused of
everything from performing a Beyonce
song in blackface to texting a sex
worker's nudes to a minor Ballinger's
legal team has denied that she performed
in blackface saying she was wearing
green face paint for a prior cover of a
song from Wicked exactly that's all they
have to say exactly what we knew was
going to happen when that one person had
to create this dumb rumor that was just
gonna give her an out to be like look at
this [__] totally fabricated no syntax
to like totally deflect so lame that the
person who put that out there did that
um
um but yeah clearly that's that's all
they're gonna mention huh yep wow
another uh interesting Passage
when reached for comment Ballinger's
lawyer replied in an email that variety
or that Vanity Fair Jesus that Vanity
Fair
wait I lost it
the vanity fairs inquiries were simply a
regurgitation of the baseless and
unsubstantiated claims that other media
outlets and individuals on social media
have reported previously
so they're saying that the accusers yeah
they're saying that things that Colleen
has been accused of are baseless and
unsubstantiated
they're substantiated they're pretty
they're like pretty substantiated I've
seen lots of posts verified some stuff
yeah we've seen they're they're
substantiated guys
and they're based and substantiated
based and substantiated
so moving on the article
paints Adam McIntyre as their villain
introducing him and saying that McIntyre
established a new YouTube identity as
Ballinger's whistleblower frequently
posting videos and racking up hundreds
of thousands of views by com by
commenting on the hypocrisy of her every
move meanwhile blah blah blah so Adam in
a video responded to this exact uh claim
and he said
how is it that I have over a thousand
videos
and
88 million views but only a handful of
Colleen videos well who cares it's his
right to make as many calling videos as
you want 100 yeah but they paid him out
to be like a crazy stalker yeah right
let's see what he says means legal team
they're trying to paint me as a stalker
they're trying to paint me as a liar
they're trying to paint me at obsessive
weirdo who's just bent on destroying her
for no reason no [__] himself
meanwhile Ballinger continued to work on
her YouTube channel is that is that the
part are you sure no no keep watching
okay meanwhile Ballinger just lived her
amazing life do you want to talk about
the fact that within those years she was
in group chats talking [__] about me in
the new weenies oh this isn't even right
yeah this isn't even out yet and
more.com hey weenies group chat that she
only laughed a couple weeks or a couple
weeks ago in which she was talking about
my drama videos that were unrelated to
her in it she was watching me more than
I was watching her but do you want to
include that do you want to include that
do you want to talk about the fact that
yeah those haven't came out yet those
haven't came out yet do we want to talk
about hold on
I'll wait
so now he's looking for screenshots that
he has a bit of trouble because there
are names in them so he doesn't really
pull up give me a moment so nothing
happens right but he does let us know
that there were two weenies chats
apparently we only knew about one those
are weenies too
Adam says they're sweeties too holy [__]
and he said it hasn't come out yet
second weenies chat has hit the internet
or relief how many this could go so deep
I mean who knows how many weenie chats
there were
yeah that's fine it's really [__] up
the way that they're not just
characterizing Adam although they go
after him by name but all the people we
spoke to oh come on they're like they're
all liars
okay so when they talk about how this
all got brought up again they do not
mention the fact that Adam what's up
I got uh okay here sorry I got off sorry
Adam McIntyre just uh left a comment
we're issuing a legal letter of
Correction retraction that's good Adam
that's good good for you
so when I'm talking about how this all
got brought up again this time around
not the 2020 time around they did not
mention the fact that Adam
there was a reason why Adam was acting
and that was because Cody posted a video
with screenshots showing that Colleen
tried to bring him down which is what
caused his response which caused this
bigger
explosion to take place and instead of
giving that preface they say
for years the drama was insular they
probably should have stayed that way but
on June 7th McIntyre posted an
anti-ballinger video as he does every so
often
I'd love to know what that click where
does that link go to I'd love to find
can you send me the link I want to read
this whole thing like I would like to
know what is their proof
of every so often I bet you it's just a
link to one other video
uh go ahead I think it links if I'm if I
if I a drama that happened with her
talking about IVF
go ahead with the with the paragraph
okay
[Music]
um
basically they just said that Adam
dropped another one this one was taught
in my relationship with Colleen
Ballinger he had new details he claimed
describing staying up with her back when
they were close and listening to her
talk about the was that the one he talks
about her sending him to underwear
yeah Adam is that the video where he
talks about she sent the underwear yes
because they don't mention that right
Adam was talking about that too they
didn't talk about the fact that she said
do you want this Adam do you want this
Adam
wait wait wait wait wait wait that was
like the big thing yeah who is this this
is so hacky I wonder if he's like just a
huge fan of her even if he's a huge fan
he knows that this reporting is
intentionally hacky because he's not
mentioning the most important part of
the video even as a fan he'd know that
hi Matthew
here's the other video they link to it
as proof that Adam can't stop talking
about her welcome back to my YouTube
channel I hope you're having an amazing
day what do we think fit check wow
stunning stunning
this is even happier than I anticipated
right um
so this is the moment where Adam sees
that when they're talking about
the allegations they say McIntyre and
another former fan instead of saying
Johnny went who was the other person who
received
porn from Colleen
via text but they didn't name him okay
headpiece
McIntyre and former fan
why is everything focused on McIntyre so
McIntyre is The Whistleblower McIntyre
is the stalker McIntyre is the the
person who will always make a video
McIntyre is the one bullying her family
McIntyre is the one that will give you
the update McIntyre is the one that
started this three years ago McIntyre's
the one that started this this and now
you're talking about someone else
speaking up against a claim in which she
sent nudes of the sex worker to them and
you're I mean of all the things that
they are [__] up this part doesn't
bother me as much I mean I don't think
they have to name him specifically you
know what I mean I guess it's just
interesting that well there it's clearly
them going on the offensive against Adam
oh yeah for sure
which is really wild I mean
this how do you get this
they they really pay off
Vanity Fair because I mean I'm alleging
that obviously I don't know but like how
do you explain such a hacky article
I have no idea how it's just it lacks so
much much research
this is intentionally misleading that's
what that's what I
I thought as well all right go ahead so
only one sentence about the solicitation
of porn to a minor in case you missed it
because it was just one
um it said McIntyre and another former
fan have also alleged that Ballinger
sent them nude photos of a sex worker
posting on posting unverified if TR if
troubling text messages as proof and
that's it that's all they touched on
that
unverified if troubling
that's written really it is written
weird right
posting unverified
I get what they're saying but no I
understand what he's saying I don't
think it's written well
yeah the post sex worker posting
unverified
and troubling if true or something yeah
but but unverified I mean
I don't think she's attempted to
say that didn't happen no as far as I'm
concerned there really is fairly
verified
I because if you look at the receipts
like Johnny posted that right yeah
the sex worker that they're also not
naming they're talking about Trisha yeah
and Trisha
denounced publicly this woman and they
didn't think to mention it
like they're purposefully leaving things
out of it to make the situation the guy
who posted the text was like super close
with her for like on the whole tour yeah
you were you worked closely with her
and
there was talk about this text
beforehand
and then he released it so
I don't you think about it the one thing
that they made a big stink about with
their lawyers was the claim
now sending porn uh sending unsolicited
porn of a sex worker they haven't said
[__] about that not being true no
interesting
so this is uh Adam's tearful response I
don't even know what to say that the
article
pretty stunning that they printed that I
can't believe it
it's so worthless and I was waiting and
I was hoping for a way back in her life
was what apparently was happening there
oh no
thoughts
uh I mean it's about to
this is our 911. for reals
the second weenie shot is under attack
now you're living that's my Vanity Fair
closing the article after all of this
like dog piling and light like flat out
lying and stuff
foreign
color what is his eye color those aren't
Hazel I'll tell you that
those are like uh
he does not have hazel eyes
brown brown
they're a beautiful brown we gotta pull
out the chart Adam and his beautiful
Browns
yeah
well it turns out everybody has hazel
eyes
actually remember you I have beautiful
Amber eyes so you just have big brown
eyes
beautiful ambers
um
blocked oh he blocked Adam yep after
tagging him why not engage with the
conversation with him dude yeah yeah
he's the one who started the
conversation you tagged him you wanted
that social media Trail
uh Adam said and Andrew Quintana the
writer of the hippies against me
has blocked me on Instagram
yeah dude you tagged him on Instagram
and then blocked him that's that's
really stupid
so in one of their tweets they spelled
Ballinger wrong and they kept deleting
the tweets reposting them because they
were getting brigaded with comments
obviously telling them to retract and so
they posted this one a bunch of
different times and then deleted and
reposted
um and they took one down
Colleen Ballinger's downfall is the
product of a particular era of YouTube
stardom where digital Persona is able to
cultivate a feverish fandom that's been
trained to reverse course with the first
spilling of tea seriously like are we
gonna diminish it
[__] seriously dude
hey girl what's the T I said what about
her brother's a pedophile
yeah like I know she didn't do that but
she gave access to kids who brother her
brother's like a straight up Chris
Hanson pedophile
have a seat over here I mean what the
[__] let's mention that isn't it weird
that uh the guy who wrote the article in
favor of her's name is Andrew and her
lawyer's name is Andrew just like
interesting
the world is a little bit too little
I understand yeah
yeah allegedly he's allegedly a
pedophile
yes I know he was flirting with a under
a child yes does that make someone a
pedophile in my opinion yes
so no uh cookies for you the no cookies
for you and then I just finished it with
this Adam tweet deer Vanity Fair your
journalist Andrew Quintana published an
incredibly def uh defamatory article
about me and includes many statements
against me that have been proven
Incorrect and it is a very malicious
attack of character and I would like to
know why an article so factually wrong
would be approved oh well they have
editors they definitely know it was
posted yeah
that's the update
second when you shot yeah uh I I showed
that already Dan thank you
still funny though
um
uh can you link me the article I
actually want to I want to read over it
someone says sorry if this is a hot take
but pedo should be canceled whoa hey you
said that sounds like some cancel
culture [__] some bygone era of YouTube
here while we're pulling that up just a
quick diversion here an enterprising
young fan sent this uh very handy chart
to help clarify the earlier conversation
here wow
okay this is useful right so I was 29.
right when I was hired and then turned
30 just a short time after that in my
first year anniversary is in 2018 right
and then I turned 31 and then we fast
forward to 2023
I've been working here for six years
three four five six correct
I thought this was the Colleen
allegations timeline no no this is a
much more I wanted much more serious
matter happy birthday Dan happy birthday
Dan so thank you uh corn corn and Cobb
uh for uh being so enterprising and
putting that together thank you very
much what was my logic again I don't
even remember because it made a lot of
sense in my mind I convinced you you
made me doubt everything you made me my
reality was shattering I was like how
have I worked here seven years I know
it's six no you really were tripping me
up and that's why I was always kind of
like what I said we'd have to go back
and watch but uh we're on the same page
now six years there you go all right I'm
gonna try to read this because when we
did this with the James Charles one I
had a lot of fun reading the article so
I'm gonna try it out with this one
um
someone take this cake for me please God
it was very good by the way thank you
cars
and a blessing of course are we eating
the mushroom cake
is that getting eaten can we hit that
quite a lot of cake it's up to cam I
guess it's just such a work of art
that's like let's just wave there's so
much of yours left too okay I don't
think we should cut all what do you you
want to save it cam or you want to eat
it uh can I take some photos of it first
and then I'll do afterwards yeah no
photos I just wanted a photo show yeah
Photoshop myself living in it first and
then we can eat it
but yeah
some people are saying I gaslit you Dan
I guess I did
I don't think that quite raises well
gaslighting is when you put when you
confuse someone and to the point where
they don't know what's real or not and I
[__] you up like that sure let's just
go with it I guess I gasped the [__] out
of you you gas me you know the era where
we used to burn the witch I do that
Aaron never really stopped the type of
witch we was burning changed right
all right
gaslighting is a form of psychological
abuse in which a person or group caused
someone to question their own sanity
memories or perception of reality get
gassed [__] you look stressed right now
happy birthday Dan
thank you thank you
Drive Angry
on your birthday now you just look
stupid all right so let's take a look
how the Miranda Sings Colleen Ballinger
Scandal went off the rails went off the
rails I mean
okay I mean the title implies that
the Scandal itself
lost credibility by going off the rails
how about here's a here's an alternative
title how Andrew quintana's career went
off the rails do you think that might be
a play on the train toxic gossip train
thing oh that would be clever that would
be clever it probably is okay Bennington
you think it's a reference to our show
that's what I was [__] better be
suggesting
gossip train so okay so everything you
know about the drama tearing YouTube
apart already it's bad sorry Klein
Badger has been a YouTuber star for more
than a decade amassing tens of million
followers
many of whom found her when they were
teenagers or even younger they fell hard
for a potty comedy
and periodically specifically her
fictional Alter Ego Miranda Sings
talentless
adolescents who delusionally believe she
can sing and also is trying to have sex
with her Uncle constantly
is that right
yeah I guess
her most comedic attempt you know what I
mean to be fair
an uncle molesting his niece is quite
funny
right I mean that's ripe for satire
right there especially for like
children's that's extra good adult
incest they love that
children watching YouTube the Persona
resonated with Outcast kids who found
her despite desire for fame to be also
accurately cringed success Aaron
Ballinger Netflix series sold out live
shows and most recently rapidly
intensifying controversy
late last month Rolling Stones published
a story alleging that Ballinger head and
grit engaged in inappropriate behavior
with underage fans the magazine verified
screenshots of text in which Ballinger
asked a minor about their virginity
status and their favorite sexual
position She also asked them to send
pictures of their body yikes well that
sounds bad already
where we go from here
however inappropriate however
inappropriate her alleged Behavior was
the article clarified that no sex crime
had been committed and that no evidence
in review even hinted at the possibility
that Ballinger had intended to start a
sexual relationship with a child okay so
it's cool then
right so they do end it by running D for
her
Ballinger did not respond to Rolling
Stones multiple Quests for comment it
depends on where they go from here but
yeah I mean they're they're running D
for her already
yes it's true
she did ask minors about the virginity
and asked them to send pictures of their
body however she wasn't trying to [__]
them as far as we can tell
good enough for me
um
[Music]
iconic that is Iconic
that is that is one of the greatest
lines in YouTube history she thought
this is good it is an earlier it's so
good
um to those steeped in the world of
YouTube fandom a chaotic shape-shifting
Minefield were a a light allegiances are
fortified and swapped by the hour all
right chill bro
it's not that crazy
many of these claims were not new
Ballinger had even already responded to
some of them Rolling Stone's piece was
tame seagully loud legally sound [__] my
dyslexia is crazy right now I literally
said seagully loud
I don't know how that I couldn't do that
if I tried you know what I mean it's
like a tongue twister a legally
thank you legally sound one could argue
compared to the language and rumors that
had been flying around for Years yet his
publication proceeded stalker
allegations again wait Ballinger getting
similarly ushered into the Main Street
Press who
Starker not oh stalker all right
let me Center myself
would you like me to read it
no I got this okay
just give me a minute I'm just pulled
together I'm centering my mind you got
it you got it I got it
I got it
a few days after the Rolling Stone piece
went live HuffPost published its own
investigation report her fans say she
groomed them as teens in the ensuing
weeks Ballinger would be accused of
everything from performing a Beyonce
song in blackface
did not happen as We Know
to texting a sex worker's nudes to a
minor Ballinger's legal team has denied
she performed in blackface
saying she was wearing so they're in
touch by the way she they're they're
intimately in touch with her team yeah
Andrew and Andrew
Andrew and Andrew tight like that
Andrew squared they call themselves
[Music]
so her lawyers say she didn't wear black
face which we know
uh
and the other second much more serious
thing uh no comment uh and sexting uh
sex workers news to a minor yeah no
comment on that uh her Sings tour has
been canceled her career abruptly
abruptly stalled and when reached for
comment Ballinger's lawyers replied in
an email that vanity Fair's inquiries
were simply a regurgitation of the
baseless and unsubstantiated claims that
other media outlets and individuals on
social media have reported
and then reach for a comment so this is
what they told them yep
because they probably didn't they're
probably like what do you think about
this
they're like okay I believe you mm-hmm
I'm cool anyone if anyone named Andrew
tells me anything I'm with them right
we in the Andrews we gotta stick tight
dog
the reality of some of these claims in
turn the broader narrative around
Ballinger remains murky various
allegations remain unverified left to
endlessly circulate as they fall under
the UN ever expanding umbrella of
inappropriate behavior okay stop
talk about the allegation
once again her lawyers have come out
against two specific points only
blackface
and uh the copyright thing claiming
videos yeah all the other stuff mum's
the word
is that's interesting or a super super
vague about
everything it's baseless and
unsubstantiated like
are you going to talk about specific
claims or no because if not we're not
listening right talk about all of them
yeah not just the ones that are not true
right
and not important really talk about the
facts in a sense this is a familiar
story for the social media age but
Ballinger's downfall is unique she
brought teams into an adult world and
made it feel like it was theirs then saw
those fans turn against her it's a
product of a particular air of YouTube
stardom of a digital Persona able to
cultivate a feverish and Savvy fandom
that's been trained to reverse course
and maybe seek payback with the first
spilling of tea I don't
we're using groom and uh spilling of tea
in the same article because that's
insane
the thing that's really Insidious is if
our parents were to just randomly come
across this they don't know they're not
familiar they just heard a little bit
about what's going on they you could
probably read this and be like oh this
is all [__] yeah it like murkies the
waters entirely you have no idea what
they're saying didn't happen What did
it's just like oh I guess none of this
really happened and it's all
just this damn cancel culture
unsubstantiated
dude the fans have been trained to turn
against you with the smallest drop of
tea
one drop of tea is all it takes sis
you could be forgiven if you were one of
the millions who back in the summer 2020
Allied some covet anxiety by diving into
YouTube's drama unfolding between
Ballinger and a former fan Adam McIntyre
bull baby you got that bold text a then
17 year old Ballinger was his Idol her
merch could be seen all over the Irish
teenager's bedroom where he recorded his
own videos he was an inspiring
influencer himself making sweet low
stakes YouTube content about his life on
June 22 McIntyre posted a video to his
channel titled Colleen Ballinger stop
lying
Annette McIntyre told several seemingly
unrelated stories
one recount to the time Ballinger sent
him lingerie in the mail to his mother's
horror
okay now I'm not even going to read this
this uh parent the parenthetical but I'm
sure it's defending her the lingerie was
new and unworn and Ballinger has since
apologized for sending it yeah
I knew it
anytime something's mentioned that it
sounds like really really bad they have
to add some parenthetical that's like
but it's not a big deal
[Music]
another was intended to debunk the rumor
that he was secretly behind some
anti-mirandicing social media account
that Bellinger had gotten wind up
a third concern
concerned the Fallout of a tweet that
Ballinger allowed McIntyre to post a
Miranda Sings from the character Twitter
account that led him to never posting on
her behalf again he'd been considered
her social media intern he said with
hopes of being employed by her one day
in that capacity Ballinger says he only
had access to her account for one day
and that if it went well she had planned
to hire him formally that sounds like
[__] what one day that's always what
she has said
um
she just gave him access for one day he
was giving her ideas and tweets for
years before she gave him her login also
I mean you can see in Adam's chat log
that it's really obvious
it it there's an ease with that
relationship that says to me that
they've been doing this for a while oh
yeah she trusted him because she was
like yeah go ahead that sounds good yep
like if that was day one would you
really be talking about posting to your
main social media like that
no I wouldn't
uh let's see between question was seized
upon and queerbating by Miranda's uh
fandom
as she came out as a Megan Trainer fan
and led to led to intense backlash
might sound strange to hear but
Ballinger had put a fan in charge of her
character's Twitter to begin with but
that access went in line with her Public
Image
yeah so again
giving a fan access to your Twitter is
weird I've never heard of that I would
never do that and also he's a minor
then again in the second part he he
attempts to downplay it but this all
this actually all made sense in line
with her Public Image what does that
even mean how did it make sense that she
gave her password out to a young fan
because of her character here he says
Ballinger was closely aligned
with her most devoted young viewers
that's it so that's why she gave her
password away to post on her social
medias no I don't think that's what I'm
saying that's like saying Blues Clues
just lets kids post to their Twitter
yeah
not necessarily correlated
yeah what we everybody has fans online
doesn't mean they get to [__] post to
their Twitter account
for her to remove that axis as McIntyre
experience felt painful McIntyre felt
that Ballinger was guilting him
selfishly preoccupied with a reputation
rather than his feelings after the
backlash she apologized for the Tweet
later she denied ever blaming uh
McIntyre and said she should have
reviewed his tweet more carefully again
dummy years here saying this was day one
here day one here's my access to my
Twitter account and then she says I
should have reviewed it more carefully
there's no [__] shot she didn't
review that tweet more carefully was day
one
it's no shot
then came the YouTube responses to
McIntyre's YouTube accusation a classic
back and forth if the name's James
Charles and tati Westberg mean anything
to you you get the idea
Ballinger is 33 at the time of her
response to a teenager posted a classic
apology Vlog she revealed screenshots of
Instagram DMS she'd sent to Mcintyre and
one that McIntyre's mother had
reportedly sent to her which seems to be
Ballinger's way of assuring viewers of
what really happened a strategy not
unlike McIntyre's in a DM she accuses
him of going too far
supposedly in response to him uh
supposedly in response to him asking her
to imagine her newborn son being taken
advantage of in the same way he felt he
had been
what
I'm referencing when Adam
texted Colleen about his how upset he
was he said like I really hope that no
one takes advantage of Flynn like the
way you took advantage of me okay and
she's like how dare you bring my son
into this like she wasn't a kid when all
of this started crocodile tears she also
elaborated upon the lingerie incident
during a live stream giveaway with her
fans Ballinger explained McIntyre had
asked for the article of clothing
according to her he'd even sent photos
of him jokingly posing in the
underwriter group chats so okay that
doesn't make it okay he's still a child
that included Ballinger and her most
noted fans Ballinger painted a seemingly
accurate portrait of the Miranda Sings
Community a silly place for kids like
McIntyre to belong looking up to an
increasingly famous and Powerful public
figure I'm not a monster I'm not a
groomer and I do not deserve to die well
nobody said nobody says you deserve to
die
rumor and monster that's debatable
Ballinger said in the video alluding to
the possibility that shiv received death
threats
so this this is very much just like uh
this is like the video she put out yeah
that everybody was forgiving her for
this is basically just that addressing
everything yeah
public opinion at least YouTube fandom
swayed back towards Ballinger though the
pendulum would sing swing back and forth
for years McIntyre established a new
YouTube identity as Ballinger's
whistleblower
no whistleblower frequently posting new
videos and Racket 100 000 views by
commenting on the hypocrisy of her every
mode they're 100
um painting Adam as
they're making it sound like every
single one of his videos is
meanwhile Ballinger continued to work on
a YouTube channel that was far from
around to sing satire culling Vlogs
offered wholesome shut up whole shut the
[__] up
Colleen Vlogs offered wholesome
lifestyle content about her kids
McIntyre appeared to seize on this
accusing Ballinger's brother brothers
family the Ballinger Family who have a
family-oriented channel of endangering
exploiting their children online how
creepy that I feel I watched them grow
up he said it's disgusting his critique
gave way to a denunciation of family
channels more broadly stood
so so do you not have a pro do you not
think that
family uh content with kids on YouTube
with zero regulations that isn't a gray
area Andrew
because you seem to be taking the side
that
Adam is just
saying this without Merit just to get
views and to talk more about Colleen
what about what he said
damn this guy's a [__] sucks
um
for years this drama was very insular it
probably should have stayed that way but
on June 7th macadara posted an
anti-ballinger video
as he does every so often
this one was tiled my relationship with
Colleen Ballinger he had new details he
claimed describing staying up with her
back when they were close and listening
to her talk about her divorce
according to maxar she uh embroiled him
in a hateful campaign against her
ex-husband
then he came to a realization that
shocked YouTube this woman used me this
woman groomed me
I said motion yet another stream of
blowback against Ballinger but this time
the word grooming captured the attention
of the mainstream press as well that's
also something that her lawyer something
was like oh the word grooming is being
misused so I they're very much in line
with their Optics on this one
uh the substance abilities alleged
grooming has not gone beyond what
McIntyre has described in his video or
what a few other fans alleged thereafter
um that this is doing a lot of work bro
this small little uh after the comma the
substance of her grooming has not gone
beyond
what McIntyre described and also a few
other fans that also said stuff like
what the [__] yeah what did they say yep
why are you telling me about her
wholesome content why aren't you telling
me about the allegations yo she
literally summarized all that [__] to
this yeah
that's like being like
okay I know this is an extreme example
but it's like uh
let me think of a good one here
Bill Cosby was accused of roofing this
girl's this one woman's drink it was
only this one time and also a few times
afterwards as mentioned a few other
victims it was only one time and it end
UPS a few other times
[Music]
that's a psychotic thing to write
that has not been interrogated by media
Outlets reporting on the controversy
either HuffPost published allegations of
grooming flexibility grooming flexibly
employ the term in a fashion not unlike
how it's weaponized in right-wing
circles against lgbtq plus no
wait why are you doing that dude why are
you making it like that yeah yeah like
why you got to make it like if you are
against Colleen then you are pro right
wing propaganda
describe Behavior does not approach the
sexual exploitation or abuse that the
actual definition of grooming indicates
I don't think groom okay did you link to
the definition of grooming what is this
there's also a definition of online
grooming which does the definition of
that does very much fall into
what we've seen no it doesn't have to be
sexual
I think traditionally it's been used
that way but it's obviously taking it's
becoming a more versatile word
uh the practice of of training someone
for a particular purpose or activity
the action of attempting to formulation
with the child or young person
with the intention of sexually
assaulting them or inducing them to
commit an illegal act such as selling
drugs or drawing a terrorist
organization well you could you could
say the weenies was a terrorist
organization
according to Child net online grooming
is where someone befriends a child
online builds up their trust with the
attention of exploiting them and causing
them harm harm caused by grooming can be
sexual abuse both in person or online or
exploitation to obtain sexually explicit
images and videos of the child but it
wasn't of the child
but it was sexually explicit images yeah
I mean sexual grooming is what her
brother did and that's clearly
on another level of that's like that
heat that's like I'm pretty sure a crime
what he's doing
but this is grooming and what do you
want you want to split hairs on that
I find it interesting how they're
running Dean saying she's not a groomer
and the two photos they used at the top
of the article are the Kids Choice
Awards
she makes wholesome children content bro
have you not seen her new wholesome
Channel yeah where she exploits her
children without any
I I've never seen I can't I mean
shut up the camera on their faces listen
it doesn't matter if they are happy as
[__] that the relationship is
exploitative
their work is dependent on their
adolescent kids working yeah it's time
to be on camera son we got to get paid
that's literally child labor the [__]
uh
I gotta go find my spot where am I
the perception of of Ballinger as a
groomer nonetheless snowballed Ballinger
eventually decided to what else post
another video on YouTube she took out
her ukulele to awkwardly sing through
her defense implying the internet seized
upon allegations that she's a groomer
for entertainment
she said she wanted her fans to be her
friends admitting that desire was wrong
I'm not a groomer she's saying just a
loser
this apparently seemed to uh
the result uh this this did work for him
I think yeah no and
waited
by the Uke
he's like yeah the uke man
it's his fave it was a little awkward
but
it was it was it was like well done she
got her point across the apology was
roundly mocked especially on YouTube
where parodies have already gotten
millions of views soon an old video of
Miranda Sings performing single ladies
in dark green makeup stop talking about
that
he he he's talked about this dumb
blackface controversy like as much as
any as like that's so nothing yeah they
love to harp on it
uh uh mate was Unearthed by former fans
to find it you need to have a copy of
her book with a QR code linking to it
who said it looked like she's performing
a blackface her lawyer sent out a
statement explaining the uses of makeup
headlines were changed although
Corrections were not issued shut up dude
what are you her [__] PR
like are you her goddamn
uh
crisis manager
that being said they should do a
correction did they not do it correction
to this guy was a huge fan oh here this
article has been updated include comment
from belanger's representative so it has
been updated dummy
not a groomer just a loser
got a groomer just a loser just a loser
uh
McIntyre and another former fan also
alleged the Ballinger sent them nude
photos from a sex worker posting
unverified if troubling text messages as
proof
racially insensitive comic performances
she performed as Miranda Sings that
Ballinger later apologized for have
reward back on social media all this is
being filtered into the current YouTube
content machine wrongdoing exposed with
the relentlessness that could rival the
anti-amber heard Brigade
anti-amber heard Brigade dropped a u do
not try to correlate situations that are
not correlated
well
the Amber Heard thing was very much uh
[Music]
I don't like it yeah again she's trying
to group her in because Amber Heard is
now like uh I think people see her as
like the I guess some people see her as
the victim of like mob Justice oh oh uh
she was certainly I think that they were
both victims of domestic abuse for sure
they both were horrible to one another I
think she was definitely dogpiled on
crazy it was pretty intense so so what
this author is attempting to do is say
if you believe Amber Heard was treated
unfairly then you also need to believe
that Colleen Ballinger was afraid of him
he's trying to make teams he's trying to
get people which is exactly what he did
before when he was like uh the LGBT
they're like yeah this is weaponized
just like right-wing circles against
lgbtq plus this use of grooming is a
right-wing hit job he's trying to Rally
up communities
for her yeah this is very manipulative
after Ballinger poster ukulele video
McIntyre poster reaction on Twitch he
was incredulous that Ballinger hadn't
apologized to him in private a reminder
perhaps that the relationship had
reached a turning point years earlier
when he sent out a tweet that briefly
got Miranda Sings canceled back then a
teenage
racket Tire perhaps
hope for sympathy another chance a way
back into the Ballinger fold
the internet is generally too cruel for
that his judgment's too Swift
but one can look at the Devolution of
the Miranda Sings Empire and see that
long that the longer drags out the
harder it is to pin down the exact truth
what they've literally only said two
things weren't true which are like the
dumbest things
justifiable outrage turns to silly memes
and headlines and videos if there's one
thing The Saga of Colleen Ballinger and
her fans has taught us it's that today's
YouTube winner is tomorrow's loser
okay
this story has nothing for it to leave
off on that was not really the takeaway
that I had from that article I think if
it's taught us anything it's that um
Adam McIntyre and all these people be
lying
okay I mean wow that was pretty ballsy
that he post that they posted this why
does it lie I think it's crazy
that they allowed that together how is
it getting
oh [__] his whole profile is down oh
[__] I clicked his profile it just says
this page you were looking for is down
okay good
[__] today's writers tomorrow's
unemployed barista
no no hate the Baristas we would tip
your Baristas people we love them
today's writer is today's non-writer
tomorrow
all right well
[__] interesting yeah no it's it's
it's truly stunning that
James Charles and Colleen are even now
able to get big Publications to write
these puff pieces it's it's astonishing
so same week embarrassing
same week two articles with the
definition of groomer right
uh
Hello Olivia uh no
all right guys as you notice Dan is no
longer in the Scorpion chair
we've been through so much Dan how does
it feel to have your butt on a seat have
your legs dangling free talk to me
seeing this see this
God is great it's great it's it's been
wonderful for my back for my
for my mental health and for um
yeah I know I don't know it's good
feels good it's good to be free nice
even once I have brazzo looking over me
now which I could never have done before
that's true I like the brazzo background
yeah the gays we're getting that gaze
for free and every dance shot it's kind
of cheating people like why do I like
dance shots so much I love looking at
Dan I just feel peaceful
uh claim us he might sue us because
we're giving away the gays for free
he's not looking directly in the camera
which is a big part of it to be fair I
don't think it works unless it's like
but I wonder if we can actually get in
trouble for showing the brats out on
poster hell no what are you gonna do I
don't know
I was brought so for Halloween
would I get in trouble for that well
that's a cut yeah
apparently no you're gonna get in
trouble yeah
I love that costume look at dance
beautiful hazel eyes guys
friends
man forget Bros so look at that gays now
that's a gaze of Miracles my friends
thank you I feel the cancer lifting of
evaporating from my body
what the hazel eyes does oh man look at
those shades of green baby
anyway the Scorpion chair is gone and
even though it's
not necessarily missed it will be
remembered
and with that being said we have made a
a memorial uh dedication to the Scorpion
chair so without further Ado let's check
that out
[Music]
we're moving to soon and Dan wanted a
new setup something like this baby zero
gravity Workshop can I get it that could
command the show from there just imagine
how cool I would look but look at how
the Scorpion flexes that's [__] sick
dude what this is so insane like who
would buy this that isn't just good food
yeah I guess that isn't the exact same
uh model but I believe it is the same
company that makes that thing I'm
actually really curious if this thing is
comfortable and actually like functional
or if it's just horrible and you hate it
oh
oh my God I am more than a mere man but
who am I
I am chair you join me in sitting
salvation
the Scorpion shares a flop I'm in the
Flop Arrow somebody said Dan you asked
for a scorpion desk instead yeah I
[__] up that was literally
uncomfortable ass chair that I [__]
hate now this is not a comfortable way
to game no not really at all it's not a
comfortable way to sit even I'm just I
can't fit it hurts my back oh your back
hurts I'd sit in this uh five days a
week for hours and hours at a time
especially when we're live in fact you
could use um you could use the Scorpion
chair and you could have a bunch of
monitors right yeah exactly you need a
scorpion chairs
okay let's trade I got you God this
chair [__] I mean all these Alpha
dudes
I'm still sore from sitting in it for
like five minutes this is I don't know
how the [__] do you do this for four
hours I don't know how Dan sits in that
[__] chair dude it's horrific yeah it
is it's horrible not that comfortable is
it Dana has been suffering in the
Scorpion chair it's a monkey paw wish
that essentially has gone wrong you got
it you got it I got it careful what you
wish absolutely I got to be frank your
choice leaves you in that chair for an
undetermined amount of time
uh no I'm ditching it next Tuesday
[Music]
thank you
there it is up you look kind of a
it's really a beautiful video
that was awesome yeah so it turned our
our original question was I wonder if it
would be comfortable that the answer was
a resounding resounding no no it was not
do not recommend but uh we have leads on
Dan's new chair the Star Trek yes I
found a very very promising lead I have
a meeting with them at the beginning of
next week to discuss it I'm a little
afraid of how much it's gonna cost but
uh really do you have an idea give me a
ballpark
a chair
because I agree listen how much could it
cost it's just a loan it's just alone
the connection that I had was I knew
somebody who had just recently hired
people to make a different Star Trek
chair just weird coincidence the Captain
Kirk's chair from the original movie or
the motion picture and uh I I think it
cost them like close to 10 grand
done done
a reverse mortgage seems a little like
some kind of trick we're going to see if
we can spend six thousand on that damn
scorpion chair yeah yeah right and and
look where it got us
sitting out if I spent ten thousand on
this chair you're sitting in that
forever no new chairs I love what you
the progression of you just getting more
and more like frustrated and angry yeah
that was a great job cam you found some
good Clips you managed to well done
because Ethan he like messaged us
earlier this week and he was like um we
got to do a a best of the Scorpion chair
and we all looked at each other and
we're like what is it it's
what's the best stuff it was nothing but
bad time no I said I set up Memorial or
Memorial or whatever yeah well yeah so
we were we were discussing but cam
nailed it he knew exactly what I meant
thank you very much right I really tried
to look for um
like props like we use it as a prop or
something no but it's always just been
in reference to us complaining about
this the one of everybody sitting in it
complaining was great I would drove at
home just universally hated
I'd spend ten thousand for the chair
okay well I I don't tell them that
well it's too late now should I hit the
button I said maybe about maybe they'll
do a trade you know we can get rid of
the Scorpions
here's the thing
I think the one that they got was like
had all the bells and whistles including
like built-in lights and everything we
could we don't want the lights I mean we
could skip that and probably get it for
a more reasonable price here's what I
need you to understand
you you
declined the offer of serious high-end
Comfort chairs for full days of sitting
and you have opted for a ten thousand
dollar prop chair uh replica of Picard
that by all accounts
is quite comfortable okay sure okay but
I just want you to know that if this
chair goes south on you there's no
you're sitting in that [__] for like 10
years I feel yeah no new chairs for
Dance I mean that's fine that's fine you
chose this
didn't you say this about the Scorpion
chair though like you're like Dan you're
gonna be sitting in this [__] Dan paid
his dues and listen I he did you
get UPS of me bitching about it were
from the last I would probably say six
to eight months and that's because I
really only started to speak up about it
more and more information now listen in
recent past Dan you paid your dues in
that scorpion chair you sat in that
thing long long
passage hits due date right I want to
take it I'm good I'm glad you don't feel
slighted there
um yeah uh well we'll see what we can do
um like I said though by all accounts
here's the thing that that show that
this share is from
they designed the set to look and feel
like a luxury Cruise liner and so even
though it's a Sci-Fi show and it's a
prop or whatever the vibe they were
going for was like
you know plush nice chairs and bio
accounts I'm just saying that's what it
feels like to sit in it so have you sat
in it no but I know somebody who has and
they said it was come to you I'm just
saying as conf even if they make it as
comfortable as possible there's going to
be a difference between that and a chair
designed to sit in for eight hours a day
but it is going to encourage me to get
up and and walk around every once in a
while and I can't get up and out of it
unlike the Scorpion chair where you're
just kind of [__] locked in there
once you sit down right
well we're all very excited for Dan's
new chair
thank you thank you me as well
I'll spend whatever I have to to make
your dream come true
I want to manifest your dreams into
reality behind you
wow if you can dream it you can will it
if you can will it you can make it right
and if you can make it you can sit in it
and if you sit in it then you are the
king
and if you're the king then this is your
Empire
[Music]
if this is your Empire then this is your
world wow
really take me places cheers
I can keep going but I don't think it's
very funny it's not working yeah
um
let's talk about the uh
the Andrew Schultz thing because this is
fantastic oh this shit's funny as hell
oh wow Robert De Niro
okay hold on this is relevant if it's
the right chair it doesn't take too long
to get comfortable in it wow
[Applause]
that's a real quote huh when was he
talking about chairs you got a deer
hunter
um
famous for its shares
playing restaurant yeah he was actually
on a um one of the what's a swivel a
nice swivel uh
in the center of Vietnamese jungle
the Herman Millers have shined all right
let's talk about and so Andrew Schultz
another Andrew we believe them all what
does it mean what does it mean
Andrew Schultz a comedian that um
has a very popular podcast uh
assumes by all accounts not a bad dude I
don't know if I've said anything mean
about him on the show I mean you know
you know me I know the name I can't say
I'm actually familiar with him but this
clip is made me like him so so he was
invited onto the nelk boys podcast full
scent now I am definitely a hater an elk
hater and I am definitely a hater of
their podcast I mean I've long looked at
this and said why
why is there anybody watching this I'm
done
um it's literally just a bunch of
Meathead Frat Boys and they're not even
like funny or smart or interesting most
people hate the sound of metal on
and um
well rice gum I mean Jesus Christ
survive right now actually I actually I
would talk to ricegum because uh what he
went through I think would be
would be uh interesting to hear about
interesting I don't know
um
but
but they get a shitload of views man and
they get like premium guests
so
I'm gonna send it like Trump was on this
[__] thing
went on
Trump Jr Hulk yeah Tucker
douches
uh uh yeah so anyway so this comedian
went on uh Andrew Schultz and this
episode and he just toasts them hard and
I it was giving Bill Burr roasting me
and I asked Dad is this what it was like
to watch it because this is [__]
horrible and you say it's not as bad
no no I said this one is worse than no I
know I know that's what I meant yeah
yeah because Bill Burr like
I don't think Bill Burr hated you he was
just entertaining himself by roasting
you I think he genuinely disliked you it
was just more like he thought he was
having fun kind of toying with you and
it was uncomfortable look this back this
it looks like he he made these guys
[__] suck yeah he's just and he his
intuition is correct he's right and this
was recorded except for Steve will do it
who we uh we forget no comment no
comment on Steve we'll do it well he
kind of he actually gives Steve a pass I
think because he thinks he has like a
mental I think he thinks he's like
special needs oh no really that I'm
putting words in his mouth but or not
what's the preferred uh nomenclature
a full sender no of of special Pizza
no not full sender are you asking about
the term neurodivergence yeah
neurodivergent he thinks Steve will do
it as diversion is fun
what if I were to say Divergent as [__]
that's that would be an offensive
probably oh God yeah so and then anyways
this podcast was erased right maybe you
were saying yeah it was uh recorded in
November of 2020 and just uploaded today
not even on their main channel on their
Clips Channel
okay and then you tell the unreleased
and then Andrew Schultz just responded
to it while we were live and I added
that as well yo so so somebody posted
the whole thing onto the clips Channel
yeah the whole thing is on the clips
Channel wow I have a feeling someone
[__] up because this is deeply
humiliating especially to this little
stymy [__] who I always I said what's
this little stymie [__] [__] boy
such a little
shame there's a little douchey it's tiny
I call him stymie because uh he stymies
the mood
um
got him dude so uh here is basically a
compilation
of
when when Andrew essentially turns on
them after I think about an hour of
talking he's just like what the [__] is
going on here so with that being said
here it is let's watch it this is stymie
I did all this Siamese right
any goofed I mean he takes it even worse
than I did
to be honest I was gonna say I think
looking back on the bill birthing
a lot of what
was going on there too in addition to my
existential crisis that I was having
before during and after was
um
very inexperienced interviewer and
podcaster there's just a lot of things
that I know now that I just wouldn't do
you know
I did everything right and they indicted
me I was in the first year of the show
it was under episode 100 for sure it's
like 30 or 50 or something yeah
you know like there's there's certain
things in conversation like
and it might seem obvious to you but
when you're interviewing someone 84
I mean that seems really early to me
that's like he's right though it's 84. I
mean it
was I mean we're at like [__] almost
a thousand probably
September oh God that's right it's on
September 11th I forgot about that oh my
God
oh no we used to talk about that yeah
yeah um yeah so I guess it was in the
second year so yeah you don't have an
excuse for that actually I take it off I
was still bad then I was bad then I'm
just kidding I I genuinely think I I was
bad then you can tell by the interview
because it seems obvious but there was
one moment where I asked him about
something he said he didn't want to talk
about it and instead of quickly moving
on to something else
I I wanted to probe that
and that um
again it might seem obvious but at the
time when you're trying to get all the
inch you're like very intentionally
trying to get all the interesting stuff
and I was I was like I'm Howard Stern
I'm going to ask about everything but
you don't understand uh
the mechanics of sitting and
interviewing someone like you want them
to feel comfortable and not forced and
not pressed uh the more comfortable they
are the less pressed they feel the more
the open they'll be and uh when somebody
says they are not comfortable with
something nowadays I just I move on
quickly you know what I mean I I don't
press it even if it's something I really
want to hear you just can't do that and
again that might seem super obvious to
you guys but it took me time to realize
stuff like that
um again maybe because I'm just a
Divergent as [__] but
I still to this day I don't think it's
cool as bad as
I mean I wasn't there but a lot of
people in chat are saying as well I
watched a lot of Bill's interviews and
he talks like that to a lot of people
it's kind of a shtick and so I could see
where you weren't really sure you know
if if he was just doing stick or not
when you asked him to elaborate but I
mean yeah obviously you've gotten better
but again I think it's just more of him
being him
people say I still do that no I don't
right well the the thing with that was
weird about it too is like I asked him
how many siblings he had he he has and
then he was like I don't want to talk
about that
which to me didn't make any sense but it
doesn't matter you got to move on
but um yeah I mean look Theo Von's a
genius and Bill Byrd decimated him in
the same way so
it's what it is
but stymie what you guys tell me what
you think about stymie so here we go
almost right now nothing nothing bothers
you you look at your phone
and everybody's feeling disinterested
were you looking at notes or or texting
no no it's yeah what do you mean me
taking time out of my day to do this and
then feeling dude I've never forcing you
guys to do the podcast I've never been
more excited to do a podcast say again
I've never been important context going
into this uh Schultz felt disrespected
because they didn't even take any time
to do research on him and he got basic
questions I I know exactly what he means
it's like if you have someone like
Andrew Schultz on or anybody he's he's a
famous comedian he has a very popular
podcast
um
people say you kind of do it though
Ethan I guess okay fine I'm a lot better
at it can I say that
um
like for example when I was talking to
fousey he was like um
I I don't want to talk about the the uh
whatever the January 15th or whatever
the [__] July 15th July 15th and I
says oh okay you don't want to talk
about it oh great move on we did come
back around to it a little bit uh
eventually but you know I've respected
that that boundary
theovan's a genius uh he's super funny I
do I love the way Theo Von's mind works
y'all are being a little bit haters on
that but that's fair I mean I understand
you he fell down the meme hole a little
bit but
that's kind of just the way it goes
these days man
so yeah if you bring someone like
nothing I'm like
um
they were like having a conversation and
like oh did you see this guy's on Tick
Tock Andrew are you on Tick Tock it was
always like what do you think of it so
dumb yeah it just was nothing like that
was pertaining to him specifically
there's one he does now where he goes
well I'll I'll let me play the [__]
clip thing nothing bothers you you look
at your phone
and everybody's feeling disinterested
were you looking at notes or or texting
no it's notes yeah literally just the
happy Dad Studios like how many [__]
cases of drinks you guys need Jesus
Christ I get it I mean me taking time
out of my day to do this and then
feeling it I'm never forcing you guys to
do the podcast I've never been very
excited to do a podcast say again I've
never been more excited I'm sorry I
don't apologize no apologize you asked
me what annoyed me and I gave you an
honest answer wait are you being serious
about that yeah that annoyed me really
yes so if someone's surprising to you
well if I'm looking at my notes I have
some things personally that I wrote that
I wanted to ask you I mean what was it
that he annoyed us before he he said I
think it was about Tate
or about something about like
trafficking or or R wording and we're
like What who is this [__] he said like
the dumbest thing imaginable you
remember what I'm talking about there's
a few things there's like the OJ
interview and a few other I think
something was Tate related
let me see
yeah was it when he was talking to
Bradley maybe when when Bradley yeah
when they were goofing on him I think he
was like but didn't the girls like
consent to like yeah yes yes that's when
we discovered the Brilliance of stymie
I think as the brain development's been
stymied
okay okay so I can't look at that and
then ask you that I mean you can I guess
what if someone in the audience is on
their phone when you're doing that and
they don't get the same treatment you
got would you call them out yes have you
done that before like again that that's
such a moronic question he's like a
professional stand-up have you ever
called out someone in your audience
before
yes
and how's that reaction how's that
reaction good what how do you
how does the audience react when you've
got I mean what the [__] but maybe he's
going through an existential crisis like
I was I don't know
I would be if I was stymie I'd be
continually questioning why am I here
why do I exist do I exist Does my brain
think so why don't my brain think so
good
they get as offensive as I do I don't
think you're offensive I think you're
offended offended yeah yeah
yeah
all right my fault there's no fault he's
he's like why is this one of the biggest
podcasts in the world what is happening
right now and I couldn't agree more with
you my friend it's fine you asked me how
I felt I gave you an honest reaction all
right my bad
[__] have you met Izzy
no but by the way I got you gotta love
too how none of his friends are coming
to his Aid like first you have Steve
will do it who's Divergent as [__] and
we love Steve will do it he's Friends
the show now but Kyle apparently who's
like the king of this [__] he's
literally just sitting there
is a Rona season I just think the
alcohol is starting to burn too many
brain cells man look at all the happy
Dad behind them
[__] brain dead dad
I'm serious man there's something wrong
with these guys
I don't think there were always this
dull
what do you think of his Vibe bro he's
the best his Vibes I saw him make a
comment at a press conference where he
was like yo I'm gonna do a tick tock
dance once I be you yeah and that really
just like made me know anymore why you
do tick tock's like three times I know
but I'm not like a date I'm not a
[__] UFC Warrior bro like I'm not in
the ring funny and somebody is what is
this yeah yeah yeah why are you on Tick
Tock I'm trying to understand like is
this your character are you like the
hater or something like what's who am I
hating on I'm just like I'm trying to
understand like you're you're hating on
Izzy for doing Tick Tock dances when you
do Tick Tock things no like I love I
love Justin
poirier's your last tick tock yeah yeah
what what the dynamic is here Samy's
gonna have to get on antidepressants
like I did after this and be able to
help him out maybe this is a turning
point you know what I have a couple
happy dads you'll be fine just sit for
three
maybe Danny will become a woke king
after this he'll come work for us right
to be my co-host
like you guys are like friends with
these people you're the newest so you
could take the shots like I'm trying to
understand what it is like you're gonna
have to see him
it's fine this is Tiny glass tick tock
that's funny yeah
he's got a sense of humor he's a
comedian that's funny I know but he's
showing the rest of the paper that's
like Tick Tock but he's making fun of
tick tocks yeah yeah see he's got a real
comedian here yeah real comedian no dap
up or no yeah yeah we're not there yet
yeah yeah yeah we're there we're there
yeah I like what you're doing are you
guys friends with each other yeah like
that's so good no why not because the
chemistry is so awkward you guys are so
awkward like the only thing that binds
these dudes together is just being drunk
I think
it's time to move on from being a frat
boy
you know
weird
why do you say that I don't know it's
just I like
I don't get it this is the best what's
what's confusing wait why did Steve get
the blur treatment what was that
dude that was awesome yeah I like what
you they did because they think they'll
get in trouble with YouTube for showing
them because he's banned
[Laughter]
that's awesome that's so funny
I love the caution are you guys friends
with each other yeah like dude that's so
funny Steve just gets blurred now he's
he doesn't exist anymore Vibe no why not
because the chemistry is weird
why do you say that I don't know it's
just I like
I don't get it what's confusing it's
just that so I can break it down for you
it's like a weird thing it's like do you
guys like do you have stories where you
like bust balls like they're yeah we
usually have a different guy who sits in
yeah we wanted to have Steve on this one
so yeah Brad yeah yeah yeah I love Brad
too yeah he's great and what Brad
usually drives it or something like that
what do you mean because he usually
driving the interview why this I mean is
this I haven't really watched but is it
always this I have a sense that they're
just sitting there with no plan
and stymie is somehow trying to lead
this podcast I mean there's just like
nothing is happening I feel like they
might have like a guy that makes a
script for them and then they just go in
blind reads the script without any
background yeah yeah is it always like
this [__] dead and weird
I don't think we're doing a good job of
that no not really I mean it's not my
favorite
this is a joke I don't understand yeah
right I gotta I don't know like do you
guys are you guys having a good time I I
was until that comes is this what it's
normally like no I mean I was having a
good time
okay I feel bad it's confusing Andrew
trust me bro I'm on the same wavelength
go watch their videos go watch I mean it
doesn't make any sense man I'm with you
100 dude
you know when Bradley Martin's the
smartest dude in the room you got
problems and no offense to Bradley we
love the guy
and I and I you know that's not a disc
to Bradley he's a very smart guy
problem I mean yeah whatever you know
love the guy he's doing his best came at
me a little bit there why do you feel
bad I just feel like you targeted me is
you or no no oh they forgot to blur
Steve we're going down baby oh [__] it's
all over
I thought you were just being a little
Annoying how
I think that I think you're annoying
really a little bit yeah yeah yeah and
what made me I actually like how he's
having so much fun with this
um this
you went full sender never go full no
very proud of this
[Laughter]
God that black face is like
that was legendary I mean can they get
away with that I think people are mad
but some aren't
it was complicated because he was
complicated yeah
I mean obviously he did it as a joke
about actors doing blackface but
subtlety is not so much
considered these days when it comes to
stuff like that anyway thanks for
bringing that up
got you you're about to get me canceled
dude don't get me speaking my mind on
[__] like that
what makes you think that
I don't know it's gonna be like a
therapy session yeah I mean what the
[__] are you I I don't know if you're
playing a character or you're having
like an insecure moment and no he's just
that dumb and uninteresting vulnerable
insecure moment then I want to like talk
about kind of playing something but what
oh
did I say that triggered you do you find
it hard to be yourself that's what I do
bro
do you think did I get [__] off
do you find it hard to be yourself
that's what I do bro
this is like he is destroying stymie I
don't know how stymie ever even got in
front of a camera again after this I
don't know a lot for doing that the fact
that they didn't post it was pretty okay
hey I kept the Bill Burr episode up okay
was that live or did we upload that
[__]
we may have even uploaded that [__]
thing yeah because we were live back
then I can't remember though that's the
difference between me and you stymie I
uploaded that [__]
you tried to bury it
with your ego let's see
uh it was live okay never mind take it
all back
kept it up though
it was live though to be around people
who are being themselves what did I do
that piss you off I wouldn't say I was
pissed off why would you say would I do
that annoyed you you were the one that
came back and said that you felt hurt I
do feel hurt because I feel like you got
pissed off at me well that's what
happens when you have real reactions
when you're being phony
with somebody a reaction you can't be
upset when was iPhone but you're doing
exactly what you should do you should
try to get your moments this is a good
moment for you bro you're crazy you
think I'm doing this for clicks even the
way your voice sounds when you say it
isn't real
are you so you think you're being real
I'm just trying to do I mean I'm
supposed to be connected with
[__] right now but like you're coming
at me so I'm curious he thinks I'm
Jewish you are aren't you good research
bro oh my God I don't even know what he
said I didn't understand
yeah what is that I I could be wrong I
know it's Yiddish but I think it's like
friend fellow Jewish Brotherhood
impressive that Andrew got that
you would do this to your Jewish brother
huh no never wow that we roll like that
wow just say how you honestly feel don't
I feel good bro I think you're pretty
you don't feel good you don't feel good
you feel insecure right now because you
think I don't like you I I do I think
why do you think I don't like you
because you turned on me like probably
like an hour 20 into the Pod and was
there anything that maybe you did to
change my energy towards you or how
about this do you think that I gave you
a fair shot in the beginning you did but
I I sent a text during the Pod and I
think that's when it turned right when
it turned I mean listen bro texting in
front of your guest face not great
he's like yeah so tell me how did you
get started
yeah that's cool
I mean what the [__] it's timey maybe I
don't know your line of questioning
after that wasn't great but I do I do
sense that you're playing a bit of a
character and I don't have as much of a
tolerance for characters as I do for
authenticity you don't think I'm being
authentic I think in certain moments you
were in that kind of like irritates me
and what can you give us especially if
it's antagonistic if you're playing
character because you're insecure and
you're just trying to do your best to
like exist in this moment which is a
high stakes moment
that's okay but can you give me an
example of when you felt that I think I
think you need attention I think you're
doing anything you can to get attention
and right now you're making this podcast
about you which is the most boring part
of the conversation we have much more
interesting Stevie my boy he loves this
wait where's the comment about Steve he
goes he comments on Steve and it's so
good is that separate it's not in this
one
um it may come later in this one this is
different than the one that you were
watching earlier try to find them being
people to discuss whose lives no oh [__]
I don't ever want to do a podcast again
straight up even that doesn't sound real
you might have just retired him oh
straight up to this [__] again
I I honestly can't tell if you're
playing a character or not and I think
that that's a real problem
you don't you just have to decide if you
do the fact that you're upset makes me
feel like you don't think I am
got it well thank you so much for
hurting my self-esteem and probably
keeping me inside tonight hope you have
a great night even that's not real
[__] Steve
just a blur
uh brutal
I mean frankly Steve will do it being a
blur kind of you get the same idea
it's okay man
a mess right
how long you been doing this
entertainment
a while I think you're a smart dude
don't get jealous
I think you're a smart guy okay I do
think you're a smart dude I I genuinely
mean that that's where mean Schultz
disagree
so far I've agreed with everything but I
think he I think he [__] up in that
analysis stymie is without a doubt very
very dumb
fun
maybe he's just trying to be generous
because he just ruined his whole life
I think that you but what makes you
think that I'm trying to do this for
myself because I don't give a [__] I'm
gonna take this out
some sort of self-benefit that's why
we're talking yeah
putting on YouTube I do this because I
enjoy it though I didn't say that you
two things can be true right yeah you do
this because you enjoy it you also do it
because you make money you also do it
because you get clout you also do it
because you get to express your opinions
sure multiple things can be true okay
right so one thing doesn't override the
other sure what I'm saying is is that if
you were being your truest purest most
authentic self I think you would have
behave differently in the podcast we've
got a different behavior from me I'm not
out here to bully someone who feels like
insecure like I think that's the worst
thing ever I think if somebody feels
interested so my bill birthing let's
just to be to go this it wasn't like
this
you guys promise because when I was
watching this I was like I know the
analogy to Bill Burr and this is so
painful please don't tell me it was this
bad and I've come to terms with it I
know it was bad not your fault you know
thank you Olivia it's not your fault Dan
assures me it wasn't that bad because
this is like it don't get me wrong it
was bad but it just wasn't Andrew was
like killing him yeah he's dead
your fault
and he's getting like real with him like
no dude we need to talk you're horrible
you're like the worst Bill never took it
to that level yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah
pretending to be something they're not
stymie if you're watching I can put you
in touch with my psychiatrist just let
me know also you had a Redemption Arc
with him too people don't like to people
don't like to remember that that part
two was [__] awesome
like and he reached out to us yeah
to come on and promote something that
was very generous of him to do that
yeah
you know that's what it is but I think
you need to find yourself a little man
I'm just I'm just trying to figure out
where where this took this turn we're
still talking about you where did this
take this turn off we don't even have to
have the mics on bro dude yo let's talk
yo bro let's step outside
now he's so clearly upset
he can't even hide it dude let's turn
the mics off dude I just want to know
what happened
well how about this I mean everyone's
[__] screaming we gotta go I think we
gotta wrap up I think we gotta wrap up
and continue the rehab session listen
stop live there's nothing
stop it stop it
stop it about me I got therapy
10 a.m to 6 p.m I got therapy so for
what you just did to me he's cute
what was that this was definitely
planned you didn't think so knock it out
I love that he thinks it's planned too
even his homies are like nah it's your
fault that was so triggered can you tell
me or not I thought you were [__]
with me it's so embarrassing dude your
fault it's your fault there was a moment
where I was like I think this kid is
[__] with me and you know we can play
that game bro everything I do is like a
joke you can't take it too seriously
the texting during the interview was
that the joke or
I mean what the [__] dude you're trying
to pull it off even right now you're
[__] with me I'm not bro I don't know
what to do with this [__] kid it
makes me feel uncomfortable bro I don't
know what it is this is planned this is
planned for sure I couldn't script that
bro I wanted to be boys bro I want to be
bowling yes right but that's how they
talk Andrew that's how they talk you
wouldn't say that
they definitely would they do that's how
they talk that's why you said it
um he's taking his dumbness of a
character he's just dumb yeah I can't
believe there's someone you can't
believe there's someone that dumb and
that successful at the same time yeah
and having a podcast I mean she thinks
there's a meta thing going on but no
he's just dumb nothing else
it's like you live in a it's like you go
oh I'm gonna go meet with uh
the head of the uh of the UN the United
Nations and you sit down and it's Jimmy
Lee yeah
and you're like what's happening you're
not the head of the U.N now that that's
his mushpuka right there and he's like
no I'm the head of the UN
and you're like that's impossible you
can't that that that's stymied
here is um
where's the clip of him talking about
Steve will do it
uh oh here it is
it's like a weird thing this is the
first time we've done a podcast I don't
do a podcast
you're an interesting one I said you
almost said you're an idiot yeah
Steve is a sweetheart you could tell
he's got a beaut he's got a gold number
I don't get it what's what's confusing
it's just that so I can help break it
down for you it's like a weird thing
this is the first time we've done a
podcast I don't do podcasts
you're an interesting one no but you're
just an interesting you're but like yeah
see he he gets it because because you
know Steve Stevie boy you know
he's just like the mentality he just
pounded like an entire [__] bottle of
tequila or something yeah he wasn't
blurred that was just his vision right
it looks like that now yeah yeah
so [__] blasted
do you guys like do you have stories
where you like bust balls like they're
yeah we usually have we saw this part
yeah so um pretty pretty incredible
footage I mean what do you guys think
about that
so apparently uh they explained why they
dropped it six days ago yeah everyone
keeps [__] coming at me I want to
make this oh stymie looks like okay
he said in a rough oh no little Andrew
look what you did actually I did want to
say it's stymie reminded me when we were
looking at the Scorpion chair
I was like dude I got huge tits like
there was a moment where like and I
think I was wearing this exact shirt
maybe or something with that had Stripes
it was a similar pattern but it was like
you could see the gravitational pull
of my titties you know what I mean like
you could see the orbit it makes yeah
and then he's got some big old giant
[__] tits on a nicer note
I love this shirt and it's always been
so so so tight
and today it fits me perfectly so that
was pretty cool
that was pretty exciting
so anyway uh that reminded me of stymie
for no reason
is it where he's sitting it just looks
like a little boy he definitely is like
a little Goblin yeah and even like the
little pot belly has I don't know if you
look like a like the character of a
goblin like they have little pot bellies
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I sent you a
picture of your Bitties if you wanna God
damn
douche oh yeah oh yeah so this is the
same shirt it's just a different
colorway
serve dude I was I was like probably I
could be measured for a cup size
probably
shout out to me for squeezing into that
thing yeah
yeah but anyway here's here's our boy uh
Stein Stein
Steinman Hyman
here
um
you've obviously seen the clip of our
president uh
uh John
was on a podcast talked about how we had
an unreleased podcast uh what was that
one Andrew Schultz and it was like he
doesn't know
oh my God
haunted you nice try dude
even even uh I like Kyle's shirt though
is that an elk merch I was thinking yeah
I was thinking also I really like the
stone behind them is really nice yeah I
have a yeah that's really beautiful
it's like Jupiter
some kind of really beautiful like
Sandstone tile marbling love that
fantastic it's beautiful
Kali gorgeous where do you get something
like that kind of fits like kinetic sand
Vibe you know hypnotizing yes yes yes
what love I was just saying it's giving
Boba Fett colors
um
colors I think for some for a piece like
that you got to go straight to the
Quarry you gotta go wholesale you wanna
go down after you wanna can you go to a
stone yard perhaps yeah uh go talk to
some Masons and um
or do we need to go straight to the dig
site slab like that ain't cheap though
man I think you got to go to the dig
site I think you got to go to the hills
where do they dig stuff like that out I
wonder Corey where's the Quarry it's one
uh down at the core one off the uh 210
Freeway we'll slash you off a piece of
the gourd come on down here now
all right back to stymie
which was unreleased unreleased and um I
think we should everyone wants to know
about it I don't really remember I think
what John like he doesn't think about it
I'm sorry I need to hear him say that
again
you've obviously seen the clip of
our president uh
John
was on a podcast talked about how we had
an unreleased podcast uh what was that
one Andrew Schultz you got to be kidding
me that's giving uh Crowder saying ETA
how do you pronounce it then
wait what is what is the shirt it says
Folsom Hezbollah
what's the connection oh
it's his his face is all melted the cats
because he was accused of uh oh right
didn't he like hurt a cat or something
wait and then oh that's kind of yeah
that video was [__] that's actually a
really important it's full scent that's
actually really [__] up Oh I thought
it was cute Pro animal abuse okay Vibes
animal cruelty approach animal cruelty
full send it caring for cats we love
that these guys always are the best huh
Andrew Schultz
which was unreleased unreleased and um I
think we should everyone wants to know
about it they all want to see it so
let's just [__] yeah I think I think
what John and by the way I didn't know
that was coming out apparently John
filmed that like months ago and it just
got released but um no yeah the the
truth with the Andrew Schultz thing is
that actually he didn't want it released
either right so I doubt that
I mean maybe he was he was probably just
like that [__] sucked that was dumb
let's not even do it yeah yeah which I
get yeah I could kind of see it but I
don't think he realizes
because I don't think he understands
what morons these guys are he looks
great in it
uh the rock is called bamboo green onyx
oh yeah I did some research is that
right oh very nice bamboo green onyx I
work with some of this where where is
this mine from we're gonna do the same
right
dude that is beautiful yeah I mean is
that is that a certain type of stone
it's from Jupiter does the Quarry have a
website Jupiter purchase it could steiny
has Drops of Jupiter oh next
there's boo
green maybe it's gorgeous here Onyx
primary refers to the parallel banded
variety of the silica silicate mineral
uh I can't help you on that one
Charlotte
so here's this is about to tell us where
it's from Onyx is natural but much of
the material and commerce is produced by
the staining of agitate Onyx was used in
Egypt as early as the second Dynasty to
make bowls and other Pottery items wow
so it's not natural it's stained that
way well it's naturally stained I think
no no oh no they they for sure
tickets processed they for sure process
sort of some sort of stone the pattern
is natural the colors are natural but
they definitely process it to make
everything vibrant and beautiful
interesting they call it naturally uh
steined they Stein is stymied it
I found this lab for a hundred bucks no
it's not that's big really it might be
how big of it yeah how was it one by one
inch yeah I'll send it
we'll send it oh that's from the same
website love design oh stymie it is from
Jupiter [__] I didn't realize
I didn't realize we were able to mine
Jupiter yet
that's exciting
uh let's see it says Onyx is a stone
that has had many definitions applied to
it over the centuries Onyx slabs bring a
level of desirable luxury to any modern
space exotic statements of nature Onyx
is a magnificent gift of nature wow it
is a gift of warmth that includes an
incredible depth of color the stone is
formed by Nature into translucent layers
of marbles it doesn't tell us where it's
from
from the Earth all right
probably not that important
but but it is gorgeous
very nice of course that's 100 slab okay
dude what contact uh Mr Ken to uh get
the uh that's unbelievable look how big
that is yeah you got to buy 1 000 of
them though oh do you oh
that was colored on with like markers
yeah Sharpie it's wood
per no no it's 200 per square meter 50
square meters
minimum is the minimum oh okay okay that
makes a lot more sense that makes sense
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
and that and this that that's the cheap
Chinese version It's ten thousand
dollars for that if it's 50 square
meters but they say that's the minimum
right
I told you the right way to do it is to
go down to the Quarry
you were right here we can find find out
how much it costs it says
uh uh cut out the middle this is origin
so they mined this in China
hmm they put a lot of beautiful stone in
China oh it's fantastic unbelievable
stonework the the oh yeah yeah no do
they have to ship it from China
I think so
I think so you'd have to put that on a
uh a ship I'd imagine right yeah you'd
have to vote that out yeah you can
definitely gotta vote that but you can
you can find some good Onyx out here
stateside
why don't we wrap up now
let's hop in my car let's go down to the
Quarry let's take a look at some get you
some stone for your birthday let's take
a look you want Onyx for your birthday
I'd love to go Stone shopping with you
you do got that hatchback yeah I'm sure
we could get some slabs in there right
let's get some slabs dude dab me up
all right anyway oh let's get from the
entire story so basically what happened
was we did the Pod with Andrew shawls
there's two main reasons dude you don't
need
two cases of happy Dad in this shot you
don't
and then a cup happy Dad
you don't want to jump the gun by Andrew
Schultz talks about that when in his
response thank God I can't wait to watch
his response but we gotta we gotta build
up to it it's actually well the reasons
we're not I don't know if we will
release or we won't I haven't really
actually asked shells if he wants to
release it now but Steve's also in it
and you guys know that Steve cannot
appear in any YouTube content at all or
our channel will be deleted he's aware
of that too so that's the best why would
you invite him on the podcast if you
have to blur him well I think they they
Bank their podcast
dude I love that he's like Voldemort
like we can't see no stalk no speak no
here yeah although that original clip we
were seeing one was unblurred well and
it said uh October
wasn't he uh he was banned before that
yeah he was bad before that I think so
because I was thinking maybe it was
filmed before the band and they just had
it in the can but um no I think nope
they're like we'll just blur them right
right Steve was actually in that episode
as well I know we could put it on
another platform too but
basically when we did the Pod with
shawls I don't know exactly what
happened between
you and him or whatever but you don't
know you were sitting right next to the
vibe was just off for some reason I
don't know whose fault it was I don't
know if it was like uh whose fault it
was
acting like he just heard about this he
was sitting on the couch I didn't
remember any of their podcasts yeah they
just I got drunk while they do it
because like nobody was doing anything
to help him or move on like they were
just watching
your fault but either way steiny and
Shoals like completely went at it I
don't even know if I went back at it I
think he thought that like I I don't
really think he like
he didn't really know you that well as
well
I think bro if he only knew me he'd like
me I swear I just want to be Bros with
them
what did he say that weirded him out
he just wants to be boys with them I
just want to be boys with you bro if we
were boys you'd totally get me he knew
me and he knew Steve and you were kind
of just starting out well that's the
thing that people don't realize this was
[__] filmed seven eight months ago
yeah it's filmed a long time ago like
almost a year ago it was New York UFC
whenever that was but um
yeah steiny and scholes went at it
because I think shulls thought that you
were like
digging at him first for certain [__] so
then he was chirping you back and then
you guys just kind of went at it for
like five minutes and then Charles was
going in on steiny and stuff like that
assistant after the Schultz they're
saying his name wrong she was saying
Shoals yeah no it's Schultz I believe
that's what I think oh is that why he
thought he was Jewish because
oh wait no it's Shoals it is it is
Shoals yeah okay never mind yeah
the scholzi the podcast
shawls just kind of approached me and
John and said can you not [__] put
your hand in your pants dude when you're
on the air
like can you just chill bro I mean
listen
I know there's a lot of happy Dad to
look at but I'm actually not distracted
the whole time
and like yo like I don't know if that
was really it like I feel like what are
you doing man
we try so hard here we work so hard and
here here's full send
I've never done anything gross or weird
on this one
scratch your balls or anything never at
least I don't show it I don't have like
a ball scratch cam
if I want to be on the Pod like we could
do something way bigger and some [__]
that's like really gonna break the
internet yeah you didn't want it you
want us to break the internet
break the internet I'm surprised they're
saying that that's like something like
Ellen would say yeah it's some boom
record
we're gonna break the internet I think
you guys did break the internet with how
badly you got destroyed by him either at
all okay well that's that that's that's
for sure the reason that's but that's
also not exactly true because I remember
saying like yo bro no you didn't bro no
no okay okay no no you're way more
accepting now yeah for sure but back
then you were like bro no I'm that's
gonna cause like you to not allow me
real quick but what I did say was yo
can we can we maybe take certain things
out and we can put it out and you said
yeah sure at the end of the day it's
up to you what goes out and we already
know like you all right so whatever as
we suspected he tried to get it cut out
um and uh somehow it still went up I
think whoever posted that must hate
stymie
so because this could have been buried
forever
one of their guys was on um what's his
name Grim something else podcast and he
talked about it and then once people
knew about it they demanded that it be
released and so that's why that's where
they messed up they mentioned the damn
thing
all right so I guess here's a here's a
clip of him talking about it from two
days ago I so this has been going on for
a minute this whole
diamond stuff all right yeah I think
like the last couple weeks since that
Graham Stefan podcast I'd love to know
what Their audience reaction to this is
all right I guess
that was on there there to here let me
read the comments did you notice the
video we were just watching the like
ratio
no it was pretty bad
the one of them addressing it yeah yeah
everyone keeps [__] I didn't look at
it okay
that's yeah I mean not like crazy crazy
every frame of him is just what's funny
I'm sorry the top comment is this
Danny's the type of dude that would get
bitten by a zombie and won't tell the
rest of the group
you can't have him around Sami is in the
delusional world where he thinks even
remotely equal he's remotely equal to
Shoals
oh even these people think it's Schultz
they put a t in there
is it Schultz or Schultz can you Google
Schultz yeah it is shelves Sunny trying
to say that nobody was laughing at
Shoals as wild we already know stymie
was getting roasted and got butt hurt
like he always does
steiny has absolutely ruined the vibe of
This Crew have y'all not realized how
creepy he makes y'all constantly not to
mention getting into arguments with
guests like Shoals is crazy dude
you're wrong with Steve will do it and
and you're the one that makes
everybody come across creepy you might
want to take a step back
all right the dog jerk off guy I think
no I think I think Steve will do it's a
good guy Dan
even if he did jerk off his dog that's
mostly what I'm referring to it's the
the dog is the most talentless soul I
have ever seen and I'm glad Andrew
confirmed it
steiny nobody was laughing Kyle I was
so wow
not good for steiny boy
I hope I mean this I don't know guys
it's all pretty weird
um let me check this clip I want to read
the comments it's like a
okay
Stein is literally the most insecure
dude on the entire planet
that pain in Andrew's face throughout
every second of this podcast is
hilarious I've never heard less
interesting questions in my life
you'll have to bring Andrew and actually
interview him I do they're not capable
who's going to interview him Steiny's
their [__] point man on this
apparently like whenever I watch
Steiny's talking a lot
who's going to interview him Steve will
do it he just pounded a bottle
the dude is barely coherent
and he's blurred
Angie said the podcast is going bad
instead of giving up he took the lead
and led 30 minutes of it what a guy
how did a guest look more like a host
than the actual host
Schultz has a point they asked him no
questions about him only a question
about what he thought about something or
something they didn't talk about his
greatness at all
yeah
all right
yeah no that makes sense
I think we lost them oh so here okay
wait so somebody
put together time stamps this is
interesting of all the times he got
pissed at him so this is the moment when
he was texting
yeah no that makes sense
I think we lost him
the cameraman cut to his ass
what are you doing dummy
okay
let's see have you ever made a joke
where you thought it was going really
well but it went really bad stymie asked
him what the deal was have you ever made
a joke where you thought it was gonna go
really well and it went really bad
yeah can you give us can you give us an
example of that uh I mean yeah I had a
lot of early in my career like I didn't
know how to get away with jokes so you
don't know that you don't have the
skills to execute them so you just say
these offensive things and then people
get offended give us an example I had
people throw [__] candles at me
what'd you say I don't even remember
shut up I honestly don't remember I
can't remember he's being generous and
answering the question yeah for you this
reminds me of when they had OJ on and he
kept pushing about the murder
and it was so [__] awkward well that
well okay oh that was good because OJ's
a [__] murderer and they should make
him squirm
this does it does in a sense I have to
be humble okay it reminds me of my old
interviewing style it's just it's rough
comes from a place of inexperience I
think
but golly that's rough let's see if any
of these others seem good what bothers
you most right now the [__] is that
question
would you call them out is this your
character are you
okay whatever I'm out I'm out I'm out
let's just see what he has to say about
this real fast release the pot
that haircut is pretty brave
release it's it's dude he's so close to
having a Hitler look
like the hair I didn't Hitler also do
that on the sides
I think you got that double zero on the
side yeah let me yeah he's so close bro
he's so CL he's just like two shaves off
for being full Zig heil
[Music]
you see what I'm saying and he's got the
hair color exact
now what
also he's an undercover Jew apparently
according to stymie oh no no maybe it's
not Hitler was killing look at that
second picture oh the sexy okay the
second picture yeah dude this is I I
know he's got kind of a stylish fashion
forward haircut where he shaved his
sides
I knew I had seen that
Hitler was right
that being said I don't think they're
much alike in any other way what about
this last one I found are you clear
about that
okay I don't remember this one but he
was pretty stylish
sheesh icy
[Laughter]
it's time for war now let's go okay
this this video went viral of the
manager of nelk uh John Shahidi
brilliant Guy and um he also has manages
a bunch of other podcasts and he's
involves some businesses like yeah like
he's connected with Elon and uh he's
just just really really interesting dude
and it's been very good to us in terms
of giving advice and that kind of [__]
and so he's on this podcast with I
believe is Graham Stefan's yeah the iced
coffee hour yeah right okay so this goes
viral
you guys ever shoot podcasts and not
post them yeah yeah it's a source object
but yeah there was one but there was an
episode with Andrew Schultz Schultz went
after like you know I think you know
when like a stand-up comedian like looks
in a crowd and decides like just go
after I just don't I I don't know why
they're running D for him
stymie is a little stymy ass [__]
somebody well I think like Schultz was
kind of like dude they're so ham-handed
with the happy Dad show I I I don't know
how to handle this this man is wearing a
happy Dad sweater they have a giant
happy Dad inflatable punching bag
a case of happy Dad four cans out he's
got a can I mean it's out of control
we went out to steiny and he um and it
was pretty awkward was it the whole
episode or was it like it was a bulk of
it it was like oh you couldn't cut
around it he would come back to him like
he just wanted to go after Steinman yep
almost so bad for Steiner
okay that's incredible
why are you going around I don't even
think it was that long uh on Stein yeah
Andrew did nothing reacted to this video
because a lot of people are giving them
[__] they're like release the [__]
episode you [__] Etc and they
basically were like
Schultz said he didn't want to put out
the episode yeah which is true
because it's okay yeah yeah yeah it was
like I think I told you guys I
definitely remember yeah it was just
like one
podcast I've
ever and
like
here's the thing here's what happened it
was
it was Steve will do it who's [__]
hilarious and he's a fan he's lost
credibility
no I'm just kidding Steve's a great guy
I can't watch the whole thing is there a
timestamp
wait a sec
something interesting
you know
look for the clip no shout out no
they're really good
okay where we got a moment here
it was like a
I think they even said
look like like we're just doing it
randomly like producers would come in
and like
angle the happy Dad cans
no way and I'd be like in the middle of
like telling a story or explaining
something like a check drop yeah and I'm
like and I'd be like you hate those yeah
exactly but it was just one of those
things where it's like I'm like I'm in
this moment we're like okay I don't
think these guys know who I am there are
moments where like none of us talked
like we just sit there like this and
I'll be like what is [__] happening
right now
oh that's so funny that makes so much
sense why he's like are you guys even
friends
I totally I totally know what he means
by that like
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh fantastic
I love it there it is now I bet you know
what
milk are good people
Adolf schultzler
guys I want to make clear I'm not
calling Andrew I don't think they have
anything alike other than hair
you know what I mean
I doubt it I don't think Andrew wants to
call to genocide Jews love I also doubt
it I don't know 100 I don't know him
well enough right but I'm pretty sure
there's a lot of Doubt there I'm pretty
sure that he does not
want that
kids loved Hitler
that's true
and stymie is kind of childlike in his
appearance in demeanor
therefore
vis-a-vis
right taimi is a Nazi
in my opinion
because kids love Hitler thank you the
allegedly whatever [__] alleged
now they've been sued for defamation I'm
always like I'm thinking things
differently
allegedly [__] I don't know
allegedly stymie's a Nazi
just kidding it's just jokes here folks
we're just doing a gag
um
there it is
pretty fun
the only thing left oh I want to give a
shout out to our place I see people in
chat apparently we have a whole uh gang
out in our place which is this Reddit
thing
where they have like real estate that
people can
uh
uh paint on and people are trying to
make huge ass
patterns or logos how do I see the board
place a tile here
so people who are looking
for
uh people to join the H3 Nation how do
we instruct them
so last year I took the lead on that
heavily I spent like days doing doing
that but I'm kind of tired or I'm kind
of bummed out that they did it so early
already
I feel like I don't have the energy to
put down
The Vibes off this year uh I will do it
because I need
but I'm pretty outside right now I feel
like it should have been a year uh
between at least but I don't know
exactly but that's okay you don't have
to go you don't have to go uh everyone
is asking me to that's why well I know
some people will keep saying so how do I
where's the where's our thing and how do
I tell people
I don't think we have one we do have one
more time
so on the Reddit people are saying let
me know they don't have the general they
don't have General love
there there is coordinates on the Reddit
can you guys do me a favor
if you want to do something for me do
does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
weinstein.com the URL
I think that'd be uh that would be a
good that's better than the H3 logo or
something yeah that would be so good so
good thank you
but uh it is incredible how committed
people get into this because it's not
easy to keep
a logo clean and look at Paris they're
like got the whole damn right side it's
not easy sure isn't
some of this is sick like what's this
art
that's the void they take over every
year
oh for real yeah
this one here yeah someone there's a
talented artist how did they even put
that together how do you do that where
so many people can participate okay yeah
the you there's a there's a chrome
plug-in
that clicks for you
oh well that's not fair yeah can we get
that for Desert Ryan does Harvey
Weinstein look like Ryan Kavanaugh yeah
but I will say last year we did it
manually we refused to that [__] but
maybe we should embrace it this year I
just want that on the board it'd be so
iconic right I look into it Bluey what's
Bluey doing on here that's like a kid
show my kids watch that
literally for like five-year-olds
not sure about that guys
um [__] spazz
yeah of course there was a lot more of
[__] spez a few hours ago
and it seems I see there's lots of spez
stuff here
uh okay well shout out to uh
the folks over at uh our place oh I see
it I see it we're to the right bottom
right and there's like a crown and it's
purple
uh yeah right there it says h3h3 on it
oh that's ours wait what's going what is
this logo
no idea they probably took over our plot
and then we kind of
it looks like peace it's under attack
yeah people don't want us oh it's a bomb
are we bomb I know we're not doing
anything we're not doing bombs we don't
I disavow bombs I don't know I don't
even know what a bomb is it looks like a
ring maybe for love like an engagement
ring no so what usually happens is
we had a plot for a while I saw and then
someone else came to took it over and
then what happens is that we make peace
usually
and they kind of combine the logo so
this is probably some random logo
combined with ours
no [__] them dude let's Okay everyone's
[__] that logo
just do A3 things on them everyone
actually what
or like just start putting down purple
there and we'll we'll make we'll make
the h3h3 Kavanaugh
dude that would be guys do that please
for me that would be so good and
especially if people go check it out
like oh wow
yeah just put down purple there and [__]
with them and we'll I'll I'll make uh
official design love the general is
coming back he's he's working I can't
believe I'm coming One Last Ride One
Last Ride boys
I'm doing it when I was or how's it
going
How does it go
when uh George Washington brings
Hamilton Hamilton and he goes one last
no not that one before that one
before he gives him command of his truth
yeah yeah yeah
when I was given my first command no
that's one last time isn't it
that's love right now
all right well it's already 4 30 so I
mean we're gonna do the tick tock trend
we can still it's just a little late how
long we've been going
we uh three hours and 10 minutes that's
insane how do we do that how does that
happen through the time so fast having
too much fun you guys let's be real
my man straight into a massacre I
witnessed their deaths first hand
that's you love
I made every mistake
where is
I've been asking
um I wanted we were all set up for me to
do a my own version of the NPC begging
Fest
[Music]
some of these people are like actually
so good at it that it's just bizarre but
like also interesting
do you know what I mean
um
God
she wasn't my fave the the first girl
was really good uh let me try to find
was it Pinky doll let me see
there was one yeah this this girl was
crazy good at it
hey hi
the restaurant like
maybe a kitchen right yeah
fascinating gang gang so did she invent
this
um
ice cream so good gang gang gang gang
yes yes yes gang gang gang gang
Ian has been saying this around the
office for the last two weeks
got me feeling like a queen and you got
me feeling like a queen
[Music]
oh thank you sir what is the noise again
it's kind of crazy how good that's it it
is interesting it is interesting I will
say that
balloon
there is someone behind her I wonder
what he thinks of all this who was that
who walked by her
uh
thank you user what is the noise again
whatever he's out ice cream's so good
balloon so everybody's on this trend you
know what I mean uh it's been kind of
done to death by this point but
so this girl pinky though was the first
person to get widespread attention
there was other people doing the same
thing what on Earth
Tana tried doing it let's take a look
so good wow
popcorn's so good mmm hot dog no
wow
I just got to say it I mean I like Tana
but compared to pinky doll
you can't even the speed isn't there
it's just that it's not she's it's not
the
I don't believe she's an NPC now here's
Jordan doing it I don't believe it she's
a main character you know what I mean
it's like man they hmm ice cream's so
good don't know how to make themselves
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes gang gang
mmm ice cream's so good attractive to
women
they're building the modern world or mmm
ice cream's so good
so we have we had an idea for ours
[Music]
um
I don't know if we have time though do
we
super fast apparently amazing
yes
I speak so good and she's so committed
she's in the zone yeah yeah yeah
that amazing
ice cream so good now yes popcorn
I I got a feeling it I'm impressed
I'm not even gonna hate
I can't
it's all love
Kai sanat did it and made six thousand
dollars I guess
like a cowboy
um oh disco oh dance you see my bad oh
I'm the king you're not he did this for
an hour
I know he oh he made seven thousand two
hundred dollars the [__] or no it's this
one probably five thousand three hundred
bro I gotta stop playing guitar on Tick
Tock man you gotta get that NPCs up I
gotta start doing this [__] dude
he may
colors that's
hey it's good for you know what I mean
an hour's work uh our girl Trisha did it
of course
she loves this kind of stuff yeah
hi Justin hi Jocelyn hi just hi Justin
hi Jason
bro sounds so good look every muscle ice
cream peaches peaches peaches peaches
peaches peaches peaches
listen no comment other than to say
it's just not on the level of Pinky doll
I'm not convinced I'm just not
there's only one goat
you're not convinced that they are an
NPC in a video game no I see here's
pinky doll again
slay huh yes yes yes yes yes
hi Carl thank you baby this is so cute
yes yes yes hey
yes she yelled at her son hey stop it
stop you're gonna break the sofa why why
you keep going like this what the [__]
do you tell your friends your mom does
for work
how do you even conceptualize that as a
child a dog I don't want a dog anymore
why why are you doing that to the dog
damn kid what'd you do that amazing
right back
okay that that was amazing I stand her
[Laughter]
so I was gonna try my own
uh
prolapse taste so good
but for the rose
you know hmm right fist me Daddy
under FF
I don't know should we try it I mean you
set it all up yeah let's try it I guess
so how do we do this so you're gonna
have to go live on your phone on on your
Tick Tock account okay
so why don't you uh get that all set up
and I have the ability to uh watch it
over here in the system and we'll just
through a full screen and follow along
see how it goes oh so ela's done by the
way she did it she did it yeah I guess
you guys won't know for like a week or
something right
uh yeah a week maybe less okay five days
or something exciting
um
no sorry I got distracted I stymied
myself oh come on
keep it together
um tick tock
that's the app I haven't gone live since
I got banned so let's see if it works I
think it will though so how is there a
whole okay there is a holder so I'm
going live okay okay
hmm
it's so good waiting to tune in
tastes so good hmm I keep refreshing
your feed oh we were gonna do the flower
thing we can do it on Monday yeah we'll
have to do it next week that's okay
I won't start right away
can you zoom on me a little bit
or maybe
is that good you think a good framing
and then Dan you're getting the feed
well have you gone live yet oh yeah I
see you now okay how are you doing that
that's interesting here we are and I see
you're already getting some roses
okay guys hold on I'm not ready yet
I'm waiting till dance sets it up
okay I have it uh here are you getting
this audio and you guys should be able
to watch it
yeah yeah okay the audio's coming
through so yeah Zach go go ahead and
mute us here in the studio and we'll
just go
yes go ahead and mute us here in the
studio we'll just go yeah
[Music]
okay ready
all right
we're good
I have a new meta I just stay here
silently
you can't even tell it's a video
[Music]
people just giving me money dude if you
want to confuse your parents send them
this these people are paying good money
okay okay all right all right
um G uh uh oh a heart thank you
[Music]
hey we genocided 50 million indigenous
folks
karate time
a donut thanks for the diabetes roses
taste so prolapse hey partner we
genocided 50 million hey partner we
genocide of 50 million
I love tick tock
oh take this Crown King
hey we genocided 50 million hey we
genocided 50 million
hey nice to see ya
heart love you too hey we just decided
50 million
hey we genocide at 50 million
[Music]
hi we're a Chinese asset oh thank you
we genocide of 50 million
oh that uh
I'm not doing you guys try it I'm not
doing that one the Mariachi hat nice try
I will protect your Chastity my lady hey
what
oh it's a hot dog thanks for the open oh
we've genocided 50 million oh we
genocide of 50 million
oh we genocided 50 million
oh I'm a Chinese asset
hey partner we genocide of 50 million
oh thank you hey partner we genocide of
50 million
oh I'm a Chinese asset
is that a Brachiosaurus no way
hey partner we genocide a 50 million
it's Friday baby
thank you
let's go I'm a Chinese asset
it's Friday baby I'm not doing the
Mariachi one
uh you're uh my lady we genocide of 50
million
we every partner we genocide of 50
hey partner we Jetta side of 50 million
people no weekend it's out of 50 million
oh uh okay hey partner we genocide of 50
million
laughs
uh what was a good one for that oh all
right thank you
we genocide of 50 million
hey partner we genocide of 50 million
hey partner we genocide at 50 million
I am a robot hey partner we gen the side
of 50 million
hey partner we genocide of 50 million
I am a robot
and I'm not doing my
number
hey my lady yeah this uh I'm not doing
the Mariachi nice try is that the Galaxy
whoa
not doing the Mariachi hey cool dude
thanks for the crown queen
um
coming to take your job
I am coming to take your job
hey partner we genocide of 50 million
[Music]
Queen
I'm a Chinese asset
asset I'm coming for your job
I'm not doing the mariachi
hey partner we genocide of 50 million
hey partner we gen decided
part we genocide of 50 million
I'm a Chinese asset
that dog is stacked
hey partner we genocide of 50 million
I'm a Chinese asset
that dog is stacked
okay that dog is very suggestive the way
it shakes its ass it's disturbing hey
partner we just out of it I'm a Chinese
asset
you get the idea right
the thing is I feel like you have to do
a lot of preparation before until that
dog is stacked
you have to do a lot of prep because I
don't know what's coming you know what I
mean
thank you King I'm not doing the
mariachi
oh thanks dude
dude why is that why did they make that
dog so stack
s
so I'm about to act up
I'm about to act up
come on get that get over here Donnie
I'm about to do some things that's
disgusting beastiality is not fun
bestiality is nothing to joke about
that's what I'll say when he comes up
hey partner we just started 50 million
bestiality is nothing to joke about hey
partner we invest we genocide 50 million
thanks so much
we made from this
yes
what I'll get banned
oh I'm saying it's not a joke yeah no
bestiality is not funny hey partner we
genocide of 50 men nor is genocide a
partner we genocide of it hey partner we
genocide of 50 million
all right
I don't wanna I don't want you guys
they're insane I I don't even know
what's going on
I'm gonna end it though because I don't
want you guys to keep giving me money
let's transition back into the studio
oh wait I want to see the total because
so they can see it all right bye guys
thank us everybody we genus out of 50
million
so it's going to show me a total all
right let's see it's loading
how long was that five minutes ten
minutes
um it was about five that felt like a
long five
damn it's just stuck loading
let's see it was like seven seven thirty
roughly seven minutes
yeah I don't know what to do it's stuck
I had to x out okay how can I find it
now
here take my phone you can do it
so anyway there that is there's my entry
into uh
hold on
enter the npz Dome NP sedum
uh man there you go
let's see if we made seven thousand
dollars
[Applause]
70 bucks
ooh prolapse so here's the ones that we
had planned but it just all went out the
door the rose was um prolapse is this
covet related ice cream got me feeling
pretty diabetic the cool hat I'm having
a midlife crisis
wait Life's too short to exercise
that's a dangerous phrase on tick tock
Cowboys committed genocide on indigenous
peoples
the panda
quick grab their semen they're going
extinct I don't want any more bestiality
references after that dog
I mean it's not necessarily but you are
grabbing their semen
GG good God what am I doing with my life
the Corgi did you find it
75 000 diamonds what is a diamond it's
almost nothing hold on
I got 75 000 diamonds oh
400 bucks I made 400 no way and there's
that short amount of time is that good
so it feels pretty good for seven
minutes a word oh yeah Tick Tock keeps
66 percent what what so dude it's funny
people complain about how [__] up Tick
Tock is for monetization and even when
you do a lot they keep 66 yeah so you
made a total of 1.1 K wait how do they
use to 400
yeah they [__] you do they justify that
at all no of course not
dude that's disgusting that sucks that
that's so [__] up that they do that
yep all right well thank you everybody I
got uh
I got a bunch of diamonds man and
there's weird limitations you can like
withdraw you can only withdraw if you
have like a thousand dollars for example
I think a thousand yeah that's such a
huge bar I'd have to double check but
it's crazy [__] like that what the [__]
yeah that's shady as hell a thousand
dollars
I'd have to double check the exact
number but
uh weekend Saturday million it says
minimum payment uh thresholds 100 unless
it changed 100 makes more sense to me
we generated 50 million weeds inside of
50 million which is ten thousand coins
maybe that's what love uh where the
confusion came from all right oh I just
wanted to talk about Crowder but guys
we're running at times five o'clock
already I gotta head home we gotta go so
I will say this happy birthday to the
two Ryman boys Dan and Kim we love you
guys thank you both yo we both have a
fantastic blessed uh birthday thank you
thank you thank you it will be blessed a
blessed blessed day
and um
what more can I say thank you guys for
being here we had a great week of shows
thank you guys everyone for watching
for once it's not about me
happy 55th birthday Dan thanks man
[Music]
it's turned 55. that's right
Golden Years baby
they called The Bull do you find the
gold in your slightly patronizing yeah
yeah it's [__] up you feel targeted
absolutely as a 55 year old man
oh what's so golden because I'm about to
[__] die all that turns to all that's
gold is all that's gold it fades once
it's lined
all the Glitters Is Not Gold no no not
that Robert Frost Nothing Gold Can Stay
there thank you
I haven't read much Robert Frost only
read Drake from poetry here's Talk About
Nothing Gold Can Stay [__] it's the
oldest person I've ever seen in my life
he's one of the greats though he's one
of the great poets
all right everybody so have a great
weekend we'll be back on Monday for
another week of fantastic shows love you
all so much good luck on the uh
on the H3 it doesn't look like it's
going very good guys I gotta say oh
but yeah thanks I mean the viewership
was so nice this week I thank you all
for being here I hope to see you
everybody again next week
so uh
[Music]
and remember I'm the realest person on
the internet by far
[Music]